- Cinema rules, turn your phone off
or put it on silent mode.
That includes you viewers
- Viewers type too loud as well Meilyne
'cause like last week, I
didn't want to say anything
but I was like, fucking all
I could hear was you typing
when (laughter drowns out speaker)
- Sounds like you're playing
guitar here by the way.
(all laugh)
(soft music)
- Welcome to this episode of Trash Taste.
It's a little darker than usual
'cause one of our lights
decided to yeet out
as we used it earlier-
- Just randomly, yeah.
- Just started strobing and
it was not a pleasant feeling.
So it's a little darker than normal,
but don't worry about it.
It's audio only-
- And I believe none of us
have photosensitive epilepsy
'cause that was like dangerous.
- That was strobing, like crazy.
- Yeah, it was full on strobing.
So we're very lucky that none
of us is suffering from that.
But anyway boys, how are you doing today?
- I'm doing all right.
(laughs)
- I'm feeling very energized right now.
- Why is that?
- I don't know, just I'm.
I had Mexican.
No, I didn't have Mexican food.
I had Thai food and my stomach was dying
and I thought I was going to die.
And then I went to the toilet
and now I feel like a 10.
- You took like two-
- Thai food does do that to you.
- You took two shits
in the span of an hour.
(Garnt laughs)
That's pretty, it's pretty remarkable.
- I'm not proud of it Joey, I'm not.
- It happens man, don't worry.
You know that like Curry
place near our house,
like literally every time
I come home, after that
I'm just like, I immediately
have to take a shit
and then I'll wake up in
the middle of the night
and have to take another shit.
- It's unfortunate being like a white guy
who loves spicy food because
my body does not agree with it
but I love the taste of it
and I suffer the next day.
- I feel like being whites,
being Southeast, Asian,
being anything your body just
doesn't love spicy food like-
- Oh really, you get that as well?
- No, I can handle spicy food,
but my stomach doesn't like it.
Like every time, like every time I fucking
like chow down on a
massive fat Indian, right?
It's like a ticking time bomb, okay.
I know-
- Why'd you describe it like a fat Indian.
(all laugh)
But I know exactly what you mean.
- It's a fucking-
- Yeah, it's a massive thing, right?
- You never just have like a smaller-
- True thing, I've never had,
I've never ordered Indian food
and been like, man, that
was just too little.
- It's going to be a fat
cor, you know what I mean?
And it's a fucking ticking time bomb.
Like I know 'cause there's a
local Indian place I order from
then they do it like proper spicy.
And depending on what time
of the day I eat it in,
like there's a timer where
I have to wait six hours
and I'm just like going to be like, okay,
this hour, I'm going to be just like
incapacitated on the toilet.
(Joey laughs)
That's just the way it's going to be.
And like sometimes when I have
it for dinner, I'm just like,
Oh no, I'm going to wake up
at like 3:00 AM sometimes
because my stomach just needs to go now.
- Oh man, I always...
Oh, go, go on.
- I was just going to say,
I hope you're enjoying this podcast guys.
Where the first 10 minutes of
talking about violent shits.
- I just thought it's
very relatable content.
Hashtag relatable
- Hashtag painful shit.
- Hashtag relatable took a painful shit.
- Question, do you think it's weird
that we like listen to ourselves often?
Like, 'cause we have to
hear our voice all the time.
Do you think that's weird?
- I mean, it was weird
when we first started off.
- Because, people at home,
have you ever listened to
your, like your voice recorded?
You probably hate it, right?
I'm assuming, right?
- I've never grown out of that.
- Yeah, you still hate it.
- Yeah, you're still...
If anyone should be grown
out of it, it's you.
- I hate looking at my own,
like hearing my own voice,
looking at my own content.
Like whenever I do a
collaboration with someone,
I watch like the bare minimum
just to get what's going on.
Like, I watch every moment of
that collab that I'm not in.
I'm just like, oh, I'm in it, skip, skip,
then oh, okay, okay.
- You're like in the comments timestamps,
please tell of when I'm not on it.
(all laugh)
So why though?
Like why can you like, I mean, okay.
Maybe it's the better question to ask,
why can we stand on our own voice?
'Cause that's pretty the weirdest side.
- Probably because we
just got used to, right?
I mean like-
- Yeah.
- I don't think anyone grew up, right.
And like, ever went into that situation.
I'm sure every family had it where,
your parents would just
be like, you know what?
There's nothing really to watch.
Oh, I found some home videos.
We can watch those.
And you're like, no, thank you.
Because I don't know.
I always fucking hated when my parents
would play home videos in front of me.
- Oh, yeah same.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- 'Cause it was always
me being a fucking idiot.
- Yeah.
But it's also like the...
I used to have like a
fucking squeaker voice
when I was like five years old.
I legitimately used to sound like
"Hi guys."
(Garnt laughs)
I legit used to have that voice.
And my dad would always
fucking rag me on me.
Like, man, your balls really
dropped all of a sudden,
didn't they?
And I fucking hated that.
Because when you're a kid,
you're not aware that you have that voice.
- No.
- Right?
- 'Cause everyone has the
same voice around you.
- Exactly! Exactly!
And you grow with your voice
so you don't suddenly be
like, Oh my voice got deeper.
Unless it's like a
really rapid growth like-
- I had that.
- You had that, yeah.
- When you're just like your
balls just fucking dropped.
- Yeah.
- I thought when it happened,
I thought it was going to go back.
I thought I was like, I thought
I was sick or something.
- [Joey] Right.
- And everyone at school
didn't believe me.
- Yeah.
But that's because your balls dropped
like a fucking cannon more, right?
Like mine kind of dropped-
Yeah, mine kind of dropped like you know,
like putting like a rock in water.
It's just a very slow drop.
- That's a very slow Joey.
(Garnt laughs)
- Well, you know what I mean?
It's like, because you grow with it,
especially if it's a natural drop
then you don't realize
that, Oh, I went from
fucking Alvin and the
Chipmunks to the fucking-
- We really talking about
this beat a bull drops now.
- Yeah.
- So you don't watch the podcasts at all?
After we...
- I like the-
- You don't want to Trash Taste?
- Wow.
- I watch like some highlights,
I don't know.
Like I...
'Cause I feel like with me
I'm just super self critical
and I've always been this way
whether it be with my work or myself.
And that's why like,
I'd say like I've seen,
anytime I see like criticisms
of my videos of my work.
I'm just, I'm more fine with it because
there hasn't been something
that's been said about me,
that I haven't already said about myself
in some way, shape or form.
- [Connor] I feel that.
- Right, right.
- So unless I'm like super
proud of a video, I really,
I find it difficult to watch it
because I see all the things that
I kind of could improve on it
or that I fucking hate about it.
- Right.
- It's just out there.
I can't like-
- So you're too much of a
perfectionist basically.
From what I'm getting.
- I hate the word perfectionist-
- But you are a perfectionist.
(both laugh)
- I prefer the term self critical.
(all laugh)
- A self critical perfectionist
is what you're essentially.
Because like you have an editor,
but you also edit your
own stuff too, right?
Like every-
- Yeah, yeah.
- You always do like
the finishing touches.
- Yeah, I always do the finishing touches.
- So wait, so-
- And like when there's a
collab where I have zero control
over it, that's just like,
I wake up in a cold sweat.
I'm just like,
(Joey and Connor laughs)
Well, what if I just look
like an asshole in this one.
- So wait, so then how
do you get through your
editing process?
Because you have to
listen to yourself, right?
Over and over and over again.
- Yeah, but-
- So are you just like cringing internally
as you're like, oh, I need
to edit this part out.
- Do you know...
' Cause you you're doing like,
you got jokes, you had punchlines.
Do you not like think,
darn! That was a good delivery.
I nailed that delivery.
- Yeah.
Sometimes I listen to a joke
and I edit it for like three hours.
I'm gonna just like, the
joke's not funny anymore.
(all laugh)
And I just cut it.
And, it's a weird thing where
depending on how my mood is,
my video could just be
completely different.
Like I could just be watching myself
and I'm just like, I hate this part.
I'm going to just rerecord
this entire segment
even though it's going to add like
two, three hours to my
fucking video making process
and then I do it.
- See, that's why I'm glad
that I'd got an editor that has complete,
that I gave complete creative freedom.
So 'cause I'm pretty sure you were talking
about this earlier, but
like at least with my editor
he leaves in shit that I
would have otherwise cut out.
- No, no.
That's what I, like, I tell
anyone I had edit for me.
I'm like, I don't care
how bad it makes me look.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Just make it funny.
- Like please make it funny.
- Because, at least, right?
You're going to get the draft, right?
And you're going to check it
and if it's really fucking bad
then you can just tell them to cut it out.
But a lot of the times it's like, Oh,
in my head, I thought this was not
going to make it into the video
but he kind of twisted it
in a way where it's like,
Oh, you know what?
That's kind of a funny
bit, I never thought about.
- Yeah, like where I like
fail a joke and I'm like
let me do that again.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And he leave that in.
- That's just a joke.
And it's like the fuck.
- I mean, I guess it's like
the difference between like
heavily scripted content and
more like improvised content.
Because there are times when I think
I have like a fucking banger of a joke
and then I watch it like
30 times as I'm editing it
and I have to like question
whether it was funny in the first place
or whether I've just seen
it so many fucking times
that it's just lost all like
comic, comedic effect to me.
- But the reason I asked
that question earlier was
because I saw a video.
I don't know if it was a Ted talk.
It sounds like a Ted talk topic, right.
It was something like, people,
everyday people should just like
record their voice and listen to it
so they can improve
their speaking in general
to be more confident.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Because their theory was that,
your overall general quality of life
and like doing anything in
daily life, improved drastically
if your speaking is more confident.
Like if your voice is more confident.
- I agree with that.
- Yeah, I would agree with that.
- And I think in general, definitely like,
if there's been the one
big thing in my life
that has done me solids
it's the voice and talking.
- For sure, for sure.
- Just going at it.
I don't know and I maybe think a lot.
I'm like, huh?
Yeah, I guess I've never
really thought about,
I mean obviously yeah,
people say, Oh, you have
a nice voice and shit.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Not to stroke my fucking dick but,
and that's the compliment
I get the most, right?
And I thought-
- I put VA in my name for a reason, right?
- You do have VA in your name, right?
- But I mean, it's the
reason I became a voice actor
because people were telling me like,
Hey, you have a nice voice
and I thought ah, maybe (murmurs).
- Fuck you know your what?
You're right.
- I'm like, damn!
I do kinda, I'm kidding.
Because when I first recorded myself,
I thought it sound like shit.
- Everyone's thinks like that.
- Right, right.
But then it's one of those
things where I think that,
it's definitely helped me a bunch
because not only have I improved
my annunciation and just
general patterns of my speech
it just made my whole life
more confident by doing that.
- Because you have
general self-confidence.
- Yeah, because if I'm
hearing it, I'm like, damn!
I sound good.
Like, is that considered as fuck?
- No, no, no.
I mean, it's just,
you just do get a skill set
by practicing it, right?
I mean, like-
- And you get happy with the
ability that you have to like
change it and make it sound
the way you want, I think.
- Yeah.
And like, I feel like even just being
on Trash Taste and just like,
like, I don't watch
every episode that I'm in
but like I still have to
watch like certain clips
just to check in everything like that.
And I feel like, especially
my speaking skills
has gotten a lot better,
gotten a lot better.
(Connor laughs)
Of course I fuck up as
soon as I said that.
Goddammit!
- A solid point.
You really drove that point
over Garnt, thank you.
No, I agree.
I used to fucking hate public speaking.
Like in school it was-
- Oh, me too, me too.
- The worst thing.
And which was weird because,
I used to be part of my
school's debating team.
Like we had like a debating team and
it was like groups of
three and you usually go
against all the schools or
whatever the fuck it was.
- We do not have this in
the UK, I don't think.
Unless you're in Oxford,
Cambridge I don't think so.
We definitely didn't have
this where I grew up.
- Well, yeah I mean,
it was literally just
the three of us that day.
And so I was, I decided to join that
because I realized how much I
fucking hated public speaking
and how bad I was just
speaking in general.
So I was like-
- How old are you, when
you decided to do this?
- This was in, actually this no,
this was an elementary school.
So this was like-
- Goddamn!
- Fifth or sixth grade.
- Wow.
- So like 11, 12 year old
Joey, was like, you know what?
I have a deficiency I
would like to improve.
I'm going to do that.
- You know what, like watching all those
like squeaker family videos,
man, I was just like,
(Garnt laughs)
I need to prove my voice man,
I don't want to sound like Alvin.
So basically, yeah.
So I joined this debating team
and of course like I was
in it for like two years
but I was still nervous as shit.
Like I was very fiddly and kind of,
I had this really bad habit
of swaying, as I talked.
- Yeah, like you don't realize
how many subconscious things
you do until you get filmed.
- This is why you should record yourself.
- Yeah.
No and that's what we did, all right.
So my parents sometimes would come
to these debating things
with other schools
and of course they would record
it just for memory's sake.
And of course, I'd be forced to watch it
during our family fucking,
family video session.
- Put it on the 4K monitor will you Joey?
- Yeah.
And so I'll watch back on
and be like, Jesus Christ.
I looked like fucking
schizophrenic patients.
(Garnt laughs)
I'm just fucking fiddling like,
(stutters)
so my conclusion is...
- Yeah, but you were 12 dude,
I would have shit my
pants to that situation.
- No, but here's the thing all the other
schools we went up against,
were just fucking shut as shit.
They were like,
yes, your honor let me defend myself
and my colleagues right here.
It's like,
- [Connor] yeah.
- And meanwhile, I'm just
like, you have a point,
but no.
It was that level.
(all laugh)
It was fucking horrible.
But then, so, I tried to use that skill
when I first started doing YouTube.
- Yeah.
- But of course, like
everyone's first YouTube videos,
it's shit.
It fucking sucks.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Of course, of course.
- And you know, I had that,
I still have this problem to this day
where I say like, and
you know, way too much.
- Yeah, same.
- And people on Trash Taste
have a point of that being like,
- [Connor] Oh yeah.
- Take a shot every time
Joey says like, or, you know
and you'll be dead in
the first five minutes.
- You have like a lot of
like everyone subconsciously
has a lot of filler words
that you don't normally
hear yourself saying,
because it's filler words.
When you say it, you kind of like
fill in the gap yourself.
And there are times when I say like a lot,
and then there are times when
I just swear a lot as well.
- It's either like, you know, or fucking.
(all laugh)
That's my three filler words.
- But also, I'm assuming that, right.
I'm a viewer, right?
Who am I to be like,
accomplishes like too much.
(all laugh)
As if they have like the
most immaculate speeches.
- Yeah right?
That's right, that's right.
(all laugh)
It's like, who are you?
Who are you to judge?
It's like, do you go around,
not saying the word,
like ever in your speech
like with any other people, like-
- I don't know.
I guess it's 'cause is it, I don't know.
I don't get it.
'Cause I understand that
everyone has shit that they do,
they might want to change, but...
Fuck there's something in my eye.
Fucking.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
Why did you need to feel the need to like
tell people I guess.
Wow, there's really something in my eye.
- Are you alright?
- You good?
- Keep talking.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
But...
What were we talking-
- We were talking-
- Oh yeah, yeah.
So like, YouTube videos
fixing your speech puddles.
- Yeah, because I feel
like when people see,
when people see doing
stuff on YouTube nowadays,
it's like the expectation is that,
for some reason the expectation is
they must know what they're doing.
They're professionals.
- Right, right.
- And it's really weird because,
I remember the first time I felt this
was when I started to get asked
to do like panels and stuff.
- Oh yeah.
- And I was thinking to myself,
I've never been good at public speaking
my entire fucking life.
And just because I have this audience,
this virtual audience of YouTube,
like conventions and stuff,
expect you to like,
be in like a top tier panelists and stuff.
I'm just like, this is
a skill I had to like
learn trial by fire.
You know what I mean?
'Cause my first few
panels were fucking shit.
And I felt like shit because
I was shit at public speaking.
But because you were forced to be put,
to put that, they force you
to be put in that situation,
you just had to learn it on the fly.
But I do find it funny that
just because we're on YouTube
people do have this
expectation of just like,
yeah, they must be really confident
and have this professional
kind fucking background and-
- Otherwise how would they
get all these subs, right?
It's like, you couldn't talk properly.
- And they seem to forget that
we all started in same place.
Making videos in our uni
bedroom or our parents' bedroom
parents' basement or something like that.
- Although to be fair in my case,
it's a little bit different
because I hated public speaking,
but I was always okay in
front of large crowds,
which is weird.
You'd think it's kind
of counter-intuitive-
- Isn't that literally
public speaking? (laughs)
- No, no, but, but.
(Garnt and Connor laughs)
No, but here's the thing.
- Is it private speaking if it's-
- No, that's the thing though,
it's like when I was doing
the debating team stuff
the most we would ever talk in
front of was maybe 30 people.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Right.
- And there's some weird, it's
really counter-intuitive but
a lot of the times I'm more nervous
in front of a small crowd
than I am a large crowd.
- I think it's more intimate.
- [Joey] Right.
- Like it's, if you have to do
in front of people, you know, especially
I think it's a little harder.
- Because I've done like,
'cause I used to do classical piano
and I played live at like
the Sydney opera house once
in front of like a thousand people.
- Oh shit, man.
- Stop dropping that
like it's nothing like,
I mean, I guess I did you know.
- That came out of nowhere.
- So, yeah.
So basically I used to do
like music, like properly
and I got the chance to perform
at the Sydney Opera House
in front of like a thousand people.
- How old were you?
- 14, 15.
- Oh wow.
- Fuck!
- And yeah, it was just like,
yeah, you're playing at the Opera House.
I'm like, like the Opera House.
- That's the Asian parents
dream right there, goddamn!
- Yeah, oh true.
My mom has never been more proud of me.
(all laugh)
That's all-
- That's never coming off the fridge.
That's for sure.
- Extra rice for you tonight.
- Did your mom fucking film
it and then like frame it-
- Of course she did.
- And then frame it then they put in like
the safe and stuff and just like, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, of course she did.
Of course she did.
- I think one thing that
really helped me realize that,
start not giving a fuck is that,
and this is just a general
life as well is that like,
I don't remember who told me this.
They were like, everyone
is always way more worried
about themselves than
they ever are about you.
- Oh yeah.
- And so like, if you just
think about it like that
and think about how you think about it
when someone is public speaking,
I don't fucking care if they're shit.
I'm just, most of the time
I'm just sitting there anyway.
Like they can just say anything
and I'll probably be like, Oh cool.
Yeah, all right.
Like, unless they like literally
shit their pants on stage,
I'm not going to think
anything bad of them.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So if you go into that mindset of,
okay, I'm going to talk
in front of these people.
None of them care really, fuck it.
How can I fuck this up?
I could be terrible.
- Yeah, but speech I feel
is a little bit different
because even if you do fuck up,
you can very quickly
try and fix it, right?
It's a little bit different when you're
playing solo piano in front of a crowd.
- No, dude you play jazz, pure jazz.
Just do it.
(all laugh)
- It's not classical
anymore it was jazz now.
- When you go on stage,
do you remember the stuff
you do and the stuff you say?
Cause I don't remember that shit.
Like, because-
- Sometimes.
- Do you still get nerves
when you have like a big
panel or a big event that-
- No, no, I don't.
- I get nerves right
up until I'm on stage.
- Same here, same here.
- So like on the, like up the
stairs going onto the stage,
I'm fucking nerves and shit.
- It's the anticipation.
It's just like, I just
want to get this over with
you know what I mean?
I just want to get on
stage and just do my shit.
- Yeah.
- I mean, the reason why is because
you know if you're doing a debate thing,
no one cares about who you are, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But when it's your panel, right?
All the people come for you.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So, I can sit there and
insult them for 20 minutes,
they'll probably be like,
damn! Connor is exactly
like he is on camera.
Hell yeah.
I'm kidding-
- Just as much of an asshole.
(all laugh)
- You know what I mean?
'Cause I mean,
that's how you deal with
like hecklers, right?
Like you just give them shit.
Everyone's like, Oh, that was funny.
You know?
- Have you ever had hecklers at a panel?
- Yeah, one time.
- Really?
- Yeah, they were like-
- Well, what happened?
- So, Oh God, it was at a
fucking Hentai panel and-
- Oh, that's the problem.
- Of course, of course.
- Dude, RA team panels,
I've never done one
because everything I've heard about it,
it's a fucking horror story.
- Oh my God! I call if
I didn't mention this
in like the convention story.
So I do, I offer to like conventions.
I'm like, Hey do you want me
to run a hentai dabbing panel?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And essentially what it is
is I just get a bunch of hentai
and I blow out the subtitles
and I'm like wing it.
- [Joey] Right.
- Just make shit up.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- People are fucking terrible at it.
And that's, what's funny.
But eventually you'll get like one person
who's actually like really fucking funny
and that's what it's for.
But I think one time I was doing it
and there's this dude in the back,
he must've been like 30
something, just on his own.
And he was just shouting cringe, cringe
cringe the whole time.
And I was like, "do you want to come up?"
And he's like, "no."
And I'm like, "well
get the fuck out then."
And everyone was like, (claps)
(laughs)
- Golf claps.
- And then late claps.
So everyone cheered.
- No joke, no joke.
- No because at panels
there's always that one guy
who thinks that like the panel
was a YouTube comment section
and they always try to like
be that fucking smart ass,
like throw out that smart ass comment
and it never fucking,
it's never fucking funny.
You know who you are.
- I don't know, I must be blessed
'cause I've never had
that at a panel of mine.
- I mean, normally those types of panel,
the people, lot of people are good
'cause you just bring
them up when you do it.
- I mean, if I ever
put into that situation
I'd do exactly the same thing, all right?
- God, it was terrible.
- I'd tell them to fuck off.
- One time there was this hentai
and it was brother and sister.
- [Garnt] Right.
- And a brother and
sister came up to dub it
and it was the most worst
thing I'd ever done in my life.
- Jesus Christ.
- Oh God.
- It was terrible.
- That's cursed.
- It was so cursed,
I regretted it.
And, you know, when you
do something you're like
this sounds hilarious.
And then it starts, you're like, Oh no.
Oh no, please stop.
Please stop.
- Is just like immediate regret.
- They offered and I was like, Oh God.
Yeah, this sounds funny.
And no, no, no, no, no.
- I've never been tempted
to do an RA team panel.
- No.
I've only seen like bad things
happen to RA team panels.
- Yeah, I've only seen and
heard the worst things happen.
- 'Cause here's the thing,
like if you come to my panel
like I'm usually open to any
kind of fucking question it is.
But it seems like when
people see RA team in a panel
'cause I've been to RA team panel.
They ask shit that is not like,
it's bad in any kind of context.
- I mean, it's not a question
it's just dub hentai,
don't fucking do anything weird
and if you do-
- No, but what I'm talking about
is like the RA team, like Q&A panels.
- Yeah, those are fucking
weird, I don't get those.
- Like I don't know what it is,
some people just think, Oh it's RA team,
therefore I can ask them
the most like private shit.
- Yeah.
- That they otherwise
wouldn't say I'm like,
no, motherfucker.
I'm not going to tell you private shit
just 'cause it's RA team.
I don't care.
- Like motherfucker even my
therapist doesn't ask this
and here you are just asking about
the most intimate fucking
details of my life.
You know what I mean?
I've never been on an RA team panel
but I've seen some of
the question that has,
some of the questions that have
been asked on RA team panel.
- It's horrible.
It's horrible.
- Yeah.
- It depends on the
crowd, doesn't it really?
Sometimes you get real like, Oh God!
and sometimes they're quite funny.
- I mean, that's the thing it can be funny
but there are just some people
who don't know what funny is.
Like, it's funny to them, but
then the moment it comes out
everyone's like, yikes, you
shouldn't have said that.
- I mean, that's like
discord humor, right?
It's like funny between
you and your friends
but not funny to everyone
else in the room.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Most of the time.
- So sometimes it's like
online humor just doesn't
translate into real life situations,
especially with a lot of discord humor.
You know what I mean?
- And you can tell when
someone's been on discord
a little too much.
When they ask questions
like that, it's like,
hmm, okay you need some real interaction.
- Man!
I saw this tweet and it
made me think about discord.
I know, I keep searching topics here but
there is someone who was like,
you can't be well adjusted
if all your friends are only on discord.
(Joey laughs)
What do you think about that statement?
- That is a take.
- 'Cause I thought about it
and you know,
and when I read that, I'm
like that seems way too harsh.
But the more I thought about it,
the more people I know who are
kind of like, I don't know.
And when I was the same,
when I had friends online
I don't think I was very well adjusted,
when I only had friends online.
- Dude, do you know what
I've imagined right now,
you know the picture of that
stick guy who's just like,
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
- That was my exact reaction.
- 'Cause it sounds too much.
- Like that's a bit of a generalization
but at the same time, I'm thinking, huh,
of the people I know who
only have friends on discord.
As in like only have friends on discord
who I've probably like,
especially people who have not seen
the anime conventions and stuff.
It's like always people who
are a bit weird in terms of like
how they are socially adjusted
and everything like that.
- This episode is sponsored by Honey.
- Imagine this, you make a list of gifts
you're going to buy for
holidays and then someone
randomly gives you the
money to help you buy one.
Sounds good, right?
Well that is what Honey's doing.
- No fucking way.
- That is exactly what Honey is doing.
- They're helping pay for $1
million worth of gifts card.
- Even Santa could not do that.
- A whole million.
- They say no more
either, this is the money.
The real gold.
- [Joey] You're probably
wondering is this the same Honey
that automatically searches
for promo codes online.
- Yes it is, yes it is
Joey, of course it is.
Why would you even say that.
- I can confirm that it is
because the script says so.
- With Honey, you can also make a list
of all the holiday gifts
you want from certain stores
and Honey will email
you when the price drops
on anything on your list.
- Just add Honey to your computer
create a free account and
throw some holiday gifts
from your drop list for a chance to win.
To win, what?
- Well, I'm glad you asked Garnt,
because Honey will select winners
and give them money to help
buy something on that list.
- You gonna win the money.
- Are we winning son?
Are we actually winning son?
- You are winning son.
If you use Honey.
- Joey, what are you going to add
to your drop list this Christmas?
- I want a PS5.
- Understandable, have a nice day.
No purchase necessary.
You need a PayPal account
to redeem the price.
- It's only valid in the US
until December the 21st, 2020
so get in quick.
- So you can get Honey for free
@joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That is joinhoney.com/trashtaste
for all your Christmas needs.
Fuck Santa, go to Honey.
- Epic.
- I feel like there is a difference
between online friends and
let's say real friends, okay.
Because you know, I
say this as someone who
has met most of my friends online
and has found my fiance
online, you know what I mean?
Like I will say that they
didn't feel like real friends
like until I saw them in real life.
I feel like that's like sealing the deal.
Because there's something about
having online friends where
there's always that wall of like,
how well do I really know this person?
You know what I mean?
And you could, there has been
like plenty of times where
I've like connected with them immediately,
you guys being like some of them.
And then there are equally as many times
when I've meet them in real life
and they're just like,
wow, you were not how I imagined you to be
(all laugh)
and this is weird now
and I feel uncomfortable.
- Yeah, we've all been there.
- You know what I mean?
And I feel like if you
just have that first step
where it is just the online relationship
you're missing out on a
big part of what it is to
be friends and be social
and everything like that.
- I mean, I've always been
since like fucking age 12,
I would happily get on fucking voice chat
and talk to like fucking 30 year old, man.
Why did I do that?
That's a-
- Yeah, that's-
- That sounds-
- I wouldn't know 11 and
12 year old who do that.
- Wait, what was the context of this?
(all chuckle)
So he invited me to the-
- Sounds like a beginning-
(all laugh)
It sounds like the beginning
to a Chris Hansen episode.
- Okay, when you feel
like cold Zombies, right?
I would gladly get on the mic and like,
I would like bully these 30 year old men.
Like (indistinct) like I
didn't give a fuck dude.
When I was 12, I would
gladly like shout at people.
Like I would be-
- Nah, I didn't have that man.
- Well, I like the-
- This is your anger
fucking coming out there.
- Like the comments said dude,
I'm a walking coin flip, someone said.
- I think you asked for Danny J yet.
- Right, you asked for Danny,
you coming out of bottom again.
(all laugh)
I love that meme.
No joke, right?
My little brother was too scared
to argue with people online.
So when he did start to
argue with people online
and I was in the other room, I'll be like,
Owen, give me the fucking headset,
I'm going to argue, you play.
So I would fucking shout at them for him
because he couldn't do that good.
And he would lose the arguments.
I'm like, you're not losing
the arguments on my account.
- Right.
(all laugh)
Over my fucking dead body.
- Do you think I would
allow you to lose that?
(laughs)
I don't know, I would just 'cause
it's one of those things right where,
I would not fall for shit
when I was like 12 or 13.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- The shit that they would try and pull.
For some reason I knew what was happening
most of the time when I was aware.
Because even from like age-
- What was happening?
- I was just fucking playing zombies
with them most of the time,
most of the chill.
Yeah, it was all good.
I mean, I don't know.
I think it was weird back
then because it just started
when everyone started voice chatting,
I think it was new and it
wasn't really weird yet.
Now it's weird if you do.
I think it's super weird.
But back then, I didn't
think of it as that weird
when I was a kid, but maybe try to-
- True, true.
- I mean, back then it
was like this new thing
and now we've so many fucking
weird stories coming up.
You gotta be-
- Yeah, now it's not...
If I had a 12 year old kid
and I heard him talking to a 30 old man,
I'd be like, what the fuck you doing?
- Yeah.
But like, I get why people
have a lot of online friends it's because
most of the time people
search for online friends
because they don't find that
connection in the people-
- Oh, totally no, I did.
Yeah, I did, yeah I totally felt that.
- Yeah, but it's the same
thing I would say is like,
when you, you can have like
the best friend in the world
but as soon as like you
move in with each other
and live in the same house
that like can change a lot of dynamics.
You know what I mean?
Especially, you know, you meet somebody,
especially in fucking uni,
you meet some people you think are chill
as soon as you move in with each other
you start hating each other. (laughs)
- [Connor] Yeah, it's true, it's true.
- And you see all their
little fucking ticks and stuff
that just get on your nerves so...
- I mean, there was like a...
I mean, I've basically been raised
like on the internet, right?
Like ever since like age 11,
I was playing Runescape, I was
doing show on Miniclip like.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I always did not
mind talking to strangers.
'Cause I always thought like,
I'm not going to give out
any personal information.
I know I never did.
For some reason I was smart enough
to never do anything like that.
And there must have been a good cha...
Maybe like a year in my life
where I pretty much only
spoke to online people
like friends that I felt
were like my friends.
Yeah, it must've been maybe
first year of university.
- It's really weird, I never had a concept
of an online friend
until I started YouTube.
- Yeah.
- Like I never would get on to, like-
- I feel like we were two
different sides of the coin
because I was always like,
I would always go on-
- 'Cause in my head I was like,
why would I talk to this
random person online
when I have IRL friends to talk to.
- Well, that's the-
- That's the thing, right?
- Well, there you go Joey,
here is where it gets sad,
it didn't at the time.
And the thing is, right?
Is that you think, Oh, this is,
like 'cause I used to see
those things on Twitter.
'Cause back then you
should see this things
like online friends are real friends.
Mom, you don't get it.
Back when Tumblr was like peak Tumblr.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I used to totally agree with that.
'Cause I was like, I was
16 and that's all I had.
And then after I like actually
got real friends I was like,
Oh, this is what normal friendships are.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
Like, it's like totally different.
It's something that like,
I don't think you realize
kind of affects you
'cause you totally think you're fine
and I think you can be well adjusted
sort of if you have only online friends,
but it's a lot harder.
'Cause I feel like having that IRL
kind of interaction to
ground you and make sure
you're not doing weird things and
that you're interacting
in a healthy way, right.
- I mean, 'cause the thing
about only having online friends
is that inevitably you are
just living in your own bubble.
It is an online bubble, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
And you live through
what you present to them.
- Yeah, exactly, right?
You're only presenting
one side of yourself
or the best side of yourself,
you're not seeing every side of a person.
So inevitably if you
just live in a bubble,
you might luck out and be like,
okay this is actually a healthy, nice,
nicely balanced bubble.
But you know, most of the time
you're missing some kind
of that social interaction.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Social connection that
you just don't get online
unfortunately.
- And I also think because
I made a lot of the
friends through gaming.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- A lot of the time
how you were as friends
was dependent on how you were in the game.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- And obviously, I was definitely
really good at the games.
So I was normally like,
yeah, I'm kind of cool.
(all laugh)
And it was one of those
things where online
when I switch this
people, like I was like,
to those friends I was
respected and they thought,
wow, this guy is so cool
he just does his own thing.
But in real life I was a fucking loser.
(all chuckle)
And it kind of made this
dichotomy in my head
where I'm like, yeah, I'm
funny, yeah, I'm charming
and then I'd go meet up with
people and I fucking struggle.
Like I couldn't, I didn't know how to
'cause I hadn't really, I
wasn't very well adjusted.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And it made me think a lot
and it makes me look
back and I don't know.
It's like, how do you convince someone
when they're in there to see it.
Like, where in that sense of,
I only have online friends.
How do you make them see that maybe that
it's not a healthy relationship.
Like it's not very healthy
because to them they might
be perfectly happy and fine.
- Right and that's the thing.
I think it's just a matter
of perspective, right?
Because to them, that's all they know.
So I don't think
until they actually
experienced the other side
of like trying to begin and
start and maintain IRL friends.
- Yeah.
- They just won't know.
They'll be like, Oh, why would I do that?
When this is so much easier
and more comfortable.
- And also I realized as well that like,
when I was predominantly
spending all my time online,
it felt like I could never
make any progress in my life.
Because I was not investing
anything in real life.
- [Garnt] Right, right.
- Maybe I'd go to work and I'd go home
but that was about it, right.
I never made any investment elsewhere.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- And I felt like my life
stagnated because of that,
because I didn't...
I think when you make friends IRL-
- 'Cause you didn't
seek out something else.
- Right, right.
Because when you make friends IRL
it's not just that it's like you miss out
on a lot of opportunities in general.
Like, because you're not
putting yourself out there.
You're not,
maybe other jobs you might hear about.
You miss out on a lot of things I think.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it's not just as simple
as having friends and
having friends it's like,
there's a lot of stuff that
comes with having IRL friends.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't know.
It's really made me think a lot recently
especially 'cause like
moving to Japan as well,
it's really made me think a lot.
- Yeah, 'cause it's been a year, right?
Since you guys moved.
- Yeah, it's been a goddamn
year since we moved here.
My God!
- Already.
- This is not felt like a year at all.
Jesus.
- Yeah, 2020 has been fucking
weird though to be fair.
But how was it for you guys,
your first year here in Japan?
It's been, I mean, to
be fair, it's probably,
pretty abnormal year for people
who moved around this time
'cause of the rona but-
- It's been a strange year all around.
- Yeah.
- I don't think,
I don't feel like I've spent
a proper year here in Japan,
mostly because like I
felt like part of the
experience I was expecting from Japan was
to have people visit me.
You know what I mean?
And I had a lot of friends who
had planned to come visit us in Japan
and it just-
- Honestly that's half the
fun of living in this country.
Right, it's like being like, Oh man,
I've always wanted to visit Japan
or like I'm coming to visit Japan.
And you're just like,
My boy, I got you bro.
- I wanted to be on
the other side of that,
on the other side of that fence.
'Cause I've been on the visiting side
and I remember how amazing shit
was when I first moved here
and everything was so bright
eyed and you could take me
to a fucking family Mart
or a Konbini and be like,
yo, yo, you eat this like
katsu Curry every day
with this fried chicken, yo-
- And you got sandwiches, what the fuck?
(all laugh)
- Just watching those interactions
is like so fucking fun
because to you now it's just so normal
but to them, it's just so fucking alien.
- Dude, I remembered like
I was at the supermarket
and I would just thought to myself,
man, I remember when I used to think
this shit was like insane.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And like, now I feel like
there's nowhere else left
on earth where I'm ever going to go
and it's going to feel magical.
And it felt kind of sad
for a second because-
- Japan is the final boss of countries.
- Because I had been
hyping up Japan my whole,
like teenage to adult life.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- It was the one place that
I always really wanted to go.
So I went to America and it was amazing.
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah, I loved it
because I'd always hyped
of America to myself.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then Japan was the last
place that I hadn't been to.
That was like, I really want to go here
'cause my parents took
me to Europe all the time
and I was kind of sick of it.
That's sounds so fucking-
- Privileged.
(laughs)
- I was sick and tired
of traveling Europe.
I mean, my parents took me to
like France every single year
and I was like, dying to-
- That sounds like a luxury dude.
- We were camping in like tents
and I just liked playing video games
and I couldn't play video
games for three weeks.
So it was basically being
like forced to be a caveman
for three weeks and like swim.
I'm like, Ugh! Okay, I
swim every day, I guess.
But I mean, it was basically
the last place I wanted to go.
And I remember the first
time I landed here,
even though I hadn't
slept for like 20 hours,
I was so fucking hyped.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- I was just, this is fucking insane.
What?
I can get vending machine, what?
(all laugh)
- It's vending machines and they work.
- I thought I would like,
I remember when I came
in for the first time
I thought if I ever move here
I'm going to get vending
machine coffee every fucking day
'cause this shit is awesome.
And now I can't fucking
stand vending machine coffee.
- [Connor] Literally every-
- Get that shit outta here.
Just give you my Starbucks
like I do everywhere else.
- When you first come here,
every vending machine you like,
I guess I'm getting coffee.
(all laugh)
It's hot coffee, baby.
But yeah, now you have it and
you're like this is the worst.
- Do you remember when
we first moving here
and you get like (indistinct)
which is all you can drink.
Like was like-
- Oh my God.
- Fucking-
- Colds life to earth.
- It was like a God sense.
Like whenever we'd go here and
we'd go to like the Zacchaeus
and we thought we'd be
going to like Keno Kuda
every fucking day. (laughs)
- It's there gnome hoda?
Not even a question, of course
- Keno Kuda is essentially
worth the sprint.
I think we said that
before, but it's very cheap,
very cheap.
It's like 15 bucks all you
can drink for two hours.
It's nuts.
- [Joey] Yeah,
something like that.
- Yeah, but then you realize
Oh, shit I actually like
my liver a little bit
and I don't want to fucking ruin it.
- And I also liked good food as well.
And there's no got bad food
but you just get better-
- It's very average food.
- Yeah.
You just get better food elsewhere.
Because I remember like coming
to Japan, like everything...
In my eyes all food in Japan was amazing
and then I lived here
and now I've realized that it's all good
but there are different
tiers of how good it can be-
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm going to wonder
what it's like when I
whenever I go back to England or something
where good food is just
so much harder to find
than it is here, where it's
just readily available.
- Well, I'm getting pot
noodle the moment I get back.
Bombay bad boy pot noddle.
- You should just like do the opposite.
You should just fucking commit
and just go to a Wetherspoons
and just be like-
- I love Wetherspoons food.
- Well then there you go but-
- That's got shit taste.
- Let's how it is.
Let's see how it is after you-
- I fuck with Wetherspoon's food.
What I don't understand is
Connor's fucking obsession
with the Tesco-
- Meal deals.
- Tesco meal deals.
- What's that?
- You had one.
- Because I forced you to.
So Tesco meal deals, right?
It's a thing in the UK for three pounds
which is about maybe just under $4, $4.
You get a nice sandwich,
a big bag of crisps
and like one of the premium drinks.
You can get like a smoothie,
you can get like an energy drink.
- Did I have that?
- Yeah, I took you because
you've got the big sandwich
and it's quite big and
get a big bag of a crisp.
You fucking loved it.
I remember you were like,
yo, is all this for three pounds.
I was like, yeah, it's insane, right?
- I think I'm vaguely remembering.
- And I really like the
sandwiches they make.
- I remember I had the
Wetherspoons that I had on
in some kind of train
station and I was like-
- Yeah.
- That was pretty bad.
I took Joey to the Wetherspoons
of Victoria station
it was terrible.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I don't think
Wetherspoons is terrible.
I like what's-
- It depends on the pub though.
- Yeah, it does, it does.
But for the most part
Wetherspoons is like pretty,
pretty decent for the price you get.
- The one there though was, we were,
I think we were struggling
to find a clean table.
Like longer than actually
deciding what to eat.
- Yeah, it was gross.
- 'Cause I remember when
Joey was coming to visit
me and Connor were like discussing,
Oh, what should we do here?
What should we show him?
Connor was like Tesco meal deal.
Tesco meal deal.
I'm getting him a Tesco meal deal.
I'm like Connor, for fuck's
sake nobody gives a shit
about your three pound
Tesco meal deal, okay.
- Right, I don't care if
I become a billionaire
you bet I'm going to be eating McDonald's
and fucking Tesco meal deals
until the day I fucking die.
That shit is value and
I won't hear otherwise.
And it tastes amazing, okay?
It tastes good.
- I genuinely don't remember eating it.
Like I feel like, I don't know.
- I'm hurt Joey.
I'm hurt, I really I'm.
- I was like, after living in
like, after living in Japan
and like living in Asia where
convenient stores just have
in my opinion, just good
food to choose from-
- I think the sandwiches in
Tesco are better than Japan.
- I mean, sandwiches have like mayonnaise
and like Ketchup and all that shit in it.
I don't need that shit.
- Okay, you're out of the question.
(Garnt laughs)
- Where does all the crust go in Japan?
Where is it?
Where's all the crust gone?
- I don't know, probably just thrown out.
- For some reasonable sandwiches
don't have crusts on them.
Where is it?
Give me my fucking crust.
I love the crust in sandwiches.
- I think though sometimes the sandwich-
- I actually that's the reason
I like Japanese sandwiches.
- Okay, in some-
- You're like a 12 year kid.
Like you can't have Mayo, you
can't eat the fucking crust
on your, this man doesn't like-
- It's still bread.
- Yeah man, what's the problem?
It tastes good.
- Yeah.
It's just wasted.
Wasted bread that's like tasteless-
- Wasted bread, it's the good-
- It tastes like bread.
- Yo, it's the flavor, dude.
It's the best part of the bread.
- What's so good, it's
tastes like cardboard.
- No, it doesn't.
No, it doesn't.
- What?
It tastes exactly like the
bread that's attached to it.
- It's like the crust on pizza, okay.
Why does crust on pizza exist
and why does everyone pretend that-
- It tastes good.
- No, it doesn't.
You eat the pizza for
the fucking bread, cheese
and tomato sauce combination.
- You're literally a 12 year old kid.
- Why would I want to eat pizza,
that is why would I just want to eat
the bread part of the pizza
where I wanna have pizza,
I want the pizza part of the pizza.
- Okay, okay.
That's because your eating it wrong.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Right?
- You're going right
up to the crust mainly,
you gotta save a little bit
of the sauce and cheese-
- Exactly then they go on the side.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No, no, no.
People think I'm a fucking
psychopath when I eat pizza,
the way I actually eat pizza
at home which is crust first.
I eat the crust first because
I get the taste of shit out of the way.
So I'm only left-
- Then how do you hold the pizza?
- I just hold it like a, like...
- What the fuck are you doing bro?
You're holding it like L
dude, like is it fucking-
- Look, look, look.
I just save the best part till last.
Why would I save the
tasteless part till last?
I don't enjoy eating the crust.
- You're making it tasteless
by only eating the crust.
- Yeah, you need to combo it, dude.
- No, no, no.
If you save a little bit of the sauce
that sauce could be with the actual pizza.
You know what I mean?
- But the pizza has plenty of sauce.
- It's like eating the fucking,
it's like when you're
having a nice fucking meal
and you eat your broccoli
and vegetables first
and you have like your chicken
or your steak afterwards
you save the best parts for last.
- Wait, do you always
everything's separate?
- Not always.
If it like synergizes perfectly, if it's-
- Like you would know.
Like you would fucking know Mr. Harmbody.
- The crust synergizes with the pizza.
- No, it doesn't.
The crust just takes the pizza taste out.
- I go fucking Italian
HAM on this bitch like
it synergizes.
- When you get those shitty
frozen pizzas, right.
That are like $1 a pound, right?
They're the ones with no crust.
- [Joey] Right.
- You know those fucking
fake deep dish pizzas
that are just all bread
and like the finish-
- They're fucking horrible.
- That's like his fucking
dream it must be without crust.
- My fucking dream is
like proper thin crust,
Italian pizzas, where like
the pizza goes right up to the crust
and it's because it's
so thin it doesn't take,
it doesn't get in the way
of the actual pizza itself.
It doesn't get into the way of the slice.
Sorry.
- You gotta grip on something.
- I don't give a shit
about greasy fucking hands
if the pizza tastes better.
- I do.
- That's just optimizing the pizza.
There is so much wasted space on pizza,
that's it's, like the
crust gets in the way
of the pizza taste.
- Well, then okay, why
don't you do this then,
when you get the pizza next time, right
and there's a thick crust,
just fold that bitch in half.
- No, because that's like, that means-
- I feel like you're making
a problem out of this
that doesn't need to be there.
- No, no, no.
- Just roll up the pizza so
that it's all in one thing
and then just-
- I just assume, right?
Whenever I see anyone who
leaves the crust on a sandwich
or leaves the crust on a pizza I'm like,
your parents clearly didn't
like beat it into you
to eat that shit dude.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- 'Cause my-
- If I left crust on bread
my mom would beat my ass.
- She'd murder me.
- She'd be like, why are you wasting food?
And I'll be like-
- I got away with a lot of shit
but leaving food was not one of them.
- Yeah.
- No, that's why if I have to eat pizza,
I eat it crust first.
Like when-
- He's just there (wailing)
- You make it sound like
a fucking torture man.
It's like.
- It is torture for me because
you're ruining this good fucking food
with just tasteless bread.
- There was only one time
where it's acceptable
to leave the crust on a pizza
and that is a buffet of pizza
where it's like I got
to optimize this shit.
I don't want none of this shit.
'Cause it's always shit crust.
- No, no, no.
- But if you just have dominoes,
then you have the crust.
- And also and like crust
just takes extra room.
It's just extra room in your stomach
that can be filled with nice tasty pizza.
I don't want to get filled
up with like tasteless crust-
- How small is your fucking stomach?
- I want that fucking pizza, okay?
- How small is your stomach?
Or I guess this tiny bit
of crust here is going to-
- I know I'm right.
I am not the crazy one here.
- How did we get on pizza. (laughs)
- I've been quiet about this for too long.
Crustless gang, where you at,
where you at crustless gang.
- All the ten-year-olds
raised their hands.
- Me.
- Point is, where is the crust Japan?
I don't know.
I don't like it if they take it from me
because sometimes I think
the best part of the sandwich
is like the give, the
crust adds to it, right?
You gotta bite it a little bit,
you gotta target a little bit.
- Yeah.
- Sometimes it just crumbles
apart without the crust,
it's like the integrity of
this sandwich has been ruined.
- It's been optimized.
- It is not been optimized.
- You cut off all the useless pieces-
- Although,
I will say sometimes 711 is
by far the guiltiest of this,
you'll get a sandwich from 711, right?
And they'll show you the sandwich,
it looks like fucking
packed in the front dude.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- This thing is like
quadruple ham slices, right?
You open up the sandwich then
you get it out you're like,
Oh my God, it's thick.
And then as you realize
you grabbing your hand
you're like, huh, it's pretty thin,
pretty thin at the end you
peel it up and there's no ham.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- At the other half of the sandwich
and you're like, I've been fucking played.
- You got fucking clique
baited by sandwich. (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
And then you have to like,
weirdly like curl the bread up
so you can get like an even bite of bread.
It's fucking.
711, can you fucking sort that shit out.
And everyone says that food is the best
but it's honestly the
worst one out of the...
Ah no, Family Mart is, okay.
- No, Family Mart is the worst.
- No, I have to stand with Family Mart.
- Oh my God-
- No, I'm a 711 simp man.
- You're a Lawson simp, right?
- Yeah, I love Lawson.
We're just looking at the Konbini.
We'll save for the Konbini.
- We're going to leave
this for the Konbini
(indistinct) okay?
- We'll do it.
We need to just you ask a-
- There are three genders.
(all laugh)
(laughter drowns out speaker)
- Oh my God.
- No, it's like the difference
between fucking Tesco's,
Sainsbury's and co-op, right?
You know, they-
- I don't know but I'll just
agree with you in that case.
- What did they have in fucking Australia?
- What, in terms of convenience stores?
- Yeah.
- Carbot, chipublic.
- Yeah, no one goes to a
convenience store in Australia.
It's all just supermarkets.
- Spike bottlers, as they say.
- No that's a liquor store.
- Yeah, I know.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Expect that is your lunch. (laughs)
- I don't want to buy
food from a liquor store.
- I will say probably the thing that I
very quickly got adjusted to
that I think that will hit me
like whiplash when I return
is deliveries here.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- Because-
- Are you speaking of optimized?
- You get so used to it here
because what happens is,
have we spoke about this
on a podcast before?
I don't think we have, have we?
- I don't think so.
- So when you get a delivery in like
I guess any other country,
it's like will arrive
between 8:00 AM and 6:00 PM.
And you just got to be home on a Tuesday,
hope you listen out, you know?
And then you fucking miss it.
- For a single knock on the door.
- And they didn't knock on the door,
they say that they were
there and it's like bullshit.
No, you didn't.
And then it's this whole fucking pain,
then you got to try and reschedule like,
Oh, we can come back in four days.
And it's like, are you kidding me?
I pre-ordered this game.
I wanted it today.
But in Japan, when you miss a package,
not only can you reschedule on that day
within a two hour time slot.
So if you miss it between
like 8:00 and 12:00 AM
which is the only four hour time slot.
- You can get it redelivered
between 12 and two,
four and six, six and eight, nine to-
- Like the same day delivery.
- Literally the whole day
and you can pick the two hour, it's nuts.
And on Amazon, when you do it
you can also pick the two hour time slot.
It's nuts.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's so insane and it works.
- I mean, there are also like,
what is it, where the UK and
stuff, some places have like
in London I have like Amazon
now or something like that.
- Yeah, we do have that.
- That's insane to me.
- I think I spoke about
that on the podcast before
when I ordered like Mario party and shit.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's when it arrives
literally a few hours
after you order it.
- Why don't we have that, man?
- Honestly, I wouldn't be surprised
if Japan gets into something.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I would love that because-
- I would never leave my
house if there was that.
I just fucking get-
- Well, it was made for groceries mainly.
- Oh yeah, right?
- It just happened to have,
like products.
- Which is weird.
'Cause I was thinking back
to our podcast last week
with the Lexion and I
remember thinking to myself,
man, how would I have survived in Japan
and got set up if Amazon didn't exist?
Like he did.
Like when he first moved
here and I was just thinking,
man, so much of my life has
revolved around Amazon in Japan
that if I didn't have it, I would be like,
life would be 10 times harder.
- It does become, when
something is on Amazon
I've noticed it becomes
about 10 times more difficult
to get the thing that I
want and delivered the-
- 'Cause you have to walk it up
and being like, all right,
where's the closest store
and then you have to find
out when the stores open
and then you have to go in
and fucking look for it.
It's just-
- Yeah.
- It's a mess.
- Moving, gross.
- But I also think I would
still feel kind of sad
because I feel that because
everything is so easy
and I got comments, a couple
of comments complaints
about not knowing Japanese
and living in Japan.
- [Joey] Right.
- Not complaining, I'm
just fucking British
and I'm just complaining about the things
that I complain about.
I know it's my fault for
not knowing Japanese.
- Yeah, he's British.
- I'm not a fucking idiot.
I know who that is
probably not a good idea
to not speak Japanese till
you get your back, right?
But a lot of people do
come here to learn, right.
And I do think that if I was forced to,
say 10 years ago or 15 years ago,
I think that I would have been
forced to learn a lot more
because I would have no choice, right?
Right now, I don't need to do anything.
Google maps tells you where to go,
Google maps tells me the restaurants.
I Google translate every webpage.
Like it's pretty much all sorted for me.
- It's catering more towards
foreigners definitely.
- It also doesn't help
that this is basically
a society that has optimized like-
- Not talking to people.
- Getting the least amount
of human interaction posture.
You go to a restaurant
and you have a tablet
and you order your stuff.
So most of the time you don't
even need to talk to anyone.
You know what I mean?
- Which is what, I like, I get,
you must get this a lot, right?
Do you get comments asking you like,
how's your Japanese coming along?
How's your Japanese coming along?
- Yeah Garnt, how is it coming?
- It is,
(Connor laughs)
- Is it Josie?
- It is, I've already
gotten Josie a few times.
(all laugh)
- It's difficult, right?
Because it's hard to explain.
Because essentially, I think
people have a misconception
of how much we interact
with Japanese people.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I talk to a Japanese person
and I'm forced to speak Japanese,
most often at the Konbini or
at the Danny's or whatever
like at a restaurant or a store.
Those are the three most common times.
And there's a script.
Like I know exactly what
they're going to say.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- They always say the same things.
- I know exactly what you mean
'cause we were getting coffee
like I think it was last week or something
at the book walk offices and
Connor ordered the coffee
and it almost sounded like fucking fluent
with all the responses he was making.
And he was just, I think it was just like,
I know how it is where you've
ordered something enough times
that you just know the
question that you get asked.
- Yeah, I've perfectly
optimized ordering coffee.
- It's like, when you watch
a movie and you see the line
before the actors say it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I know what you're going to say.
- I know where the, if
that script is like varied
like in the slightest, you
just go, you just go, like
I have no idea what the
fuck I'm doing anymore.
- Because what happens is I'll
be ordering coffee, right.
And here's the order every single time.
You go in there, you say what you want,
they'll ask you, do you
want it to stay or to go.
So your gonna say to go.
And then they'll ask
you, do you want a bag?
You say, no, you don't want a bag.
And then you just say how you want to pay.
So you can just say that, right.
And it's always how it is.
And every time it goes
wrong and if Joey's with me
I'll just slowly turn
to Joey and be like...
(Joey chuckles)
- There's only two times
I've seen a slow head turn
and that's in a horror movie
and when I'm with you guys
and it's out of the script,
it's just very slow like, help.
- Yeah, I don't want to go, Joey help.
I just wanna be like,
dozo Joey.
- I'll leave it.
- It's actually funny
when you're not there
'cause when it's, there have been times
when it's just me and Connor
and we're at like a
restaurant ordering something
and then we get something off script
and it's both of us trying to like,
cumminisively figure out
which one of us knows like
as much Japanese as each other.
Like, we're trying to like combine
our Japanese knowledge to be
like, okay, you know this word,
I know that word so we can,
let's try and figure out what were saying.
- Let's combine these two words together.
That's the thing though
like, that's like one...
Like I'm such a fucking sadist but like,
that's the one thing I fucking love when
friends who can't speak
Japanese, I'm hanging out with-
- But are assholes.
- And we go to like a
restaurant or something
or we go out somewhere or we
go traveling somewhere is that,
because I don't look Japanese,
people don't expect me to know Japanese.
- Yeah.
- So I love every now and
then going to a restaurant
with like a bunch of non Japanese friends
and pretending I can't
speak a word of Japanese
and just letting them be.
I'm like, (speaks in a foreign language)
and there just like, fuck you.
Fuck you Joey.
- So yeah, outside of those situations,
we pretty much don't really
speak to Japanese people.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Although to be fair you've been recently
fucking interacting with like-
- Yeah.
- Japanese people on Apex, right?
- Well, so I thought to myself, right?
I'm taking these Japanese
classes two times a week,
problem is I'm not really
doing much outside of that
and then people will be like,
Oh, why don't you study more?
I mean, the work schedule
that we have is already
pretty fucking hectic.
- And there's only so much studying
before you have to actually
use it in practice.
- I think like, no matter
how much study I do
if I'm not using it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like practically,
it's not going to help.
So yeah, I just decided, fuck it.
Okay, you know what?
I'm going to stream talking
to Japanese people on Apex.
Just trying to make friends.
I wanna just to make some
friends pretty fucking fast.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Even though most people
do not want to talk.
- I mean, I was tuning
into one of your streams
and you were like interacting quite well.
- I can speak super, super basic and-
- But they were getting it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They can normally understand
what I'm trying to say.
The best thing is is that
if I don't know something,
I'm like chat, chat, what is this word?
How do I say this thing?
And then they tell me,
and I don't forget it
because I'm using it.
Like immediately over and over.
And so that's been a really helpful.
And if you want to go and
watch those, you can watch them
on the highlights, whatever (murmurs)
But yeah, that's been super helpful.
But outside of that, like
we don't fucking use it.
Like-
- I mean,
you can use, I can talk
to you guys in Japanese.
- But it's, okay Joey,
it's different 'cause-
- It's different Joey.
- Because you know how bad we are
and it's embarrassing right?
- No, no, okay, okay.
You have to throw that aside because like-
- I'm fine doing it in
front of 2000 people live.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But not in front of me?
- No, not in front of you.
- Why?
- Because-
- I'm not going to judge you.
- Joey's a smart motherfucker.
- We know, that's not the point
we judge ourselves when we're with you.
It's like a subconscious
thing where I'm just like-
- I don't want you to be
disappointed in me Joey.
(laughs)
- I'm not going to be disappointed.
- I want to just impress you, man.
I want to impress you, okay?
I just want to get new hunger
Josie by you man, okay.
But I know how Josie
your Japanese is, man.
I can't reach that level right now, man.
- You're like trying to
impress your dad is like,
come on man, this is the only
time I go get my dad's love.
- Because,
I don't know what it is about
talking to a Japanese person,
even though it's even more awkward
'cause if they don't
understand me, we're fucked
but it's less awkward because they
inherently expect me to be fucking awful.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So it's like when I do do
good, it's like, Oh awesome.
Like it's good but-
- So why don't you just put that on me?
- Because you can pretty figure
out what I'm trying to say
and you can be like are you
trying to say this Connor but...
- But I can also just pretend to be like,
- I guess maybe.
(speaks in a foreign language)
The point is in general,
we don't really get to talk to as many
Japanese people as I
think people expect us to.
- Yeah.
- Right, right, right.
- The sponsor of today's
video is EJ Anime store.
Kind of count as official
online anime merch store
caters directly towards
overseas anime fans
delivering the newest
and most exclusive merch
of all your favorite
shows directly from Japan.
- Damn! That sounds fucking like Eminem.
- Did I just like hit the like 1.5
speed on YouTube or something.
(mumbles)
- Did you know, (mumbles).
(all laugh)
- Look at all these
awesome things you can buy
from EJ Anime store.
- Yes.
- Many of the products are only available
for purchase during a limited
time reservation period,
so be sure check the pre-order
deadlines shown on screen.
- I feel sorry for anyone
watching at times (indistinct)
(all laugh)
- So first line up week on.
- First of all, we have
the Hara here Susan Mia.
- [Connor] Ooh.
- Woodblock prints.
- I'm very scared to touch this,
it's very-
- [Garnt] Oh my God.
- This is limited quantities
by the way, limited numbers
- And there is a name for this.
I'm going to attempt to pronounce it.
- It's like a Welsh town name.
(all laugh)
- That's what I thought.
It's a welsh town name.
Look at this on screen.
Okay, let's try to pronounce this.
Ichimangosenyonhyakukyuujuuhachi-kei
- Yeah, that was it.
It was perfect.
- Yeah, 'cause it's numbers, right?
Ichimangosenyonhyakukyuujuuhachi-kei
- I forget the Japanese
words don't have spaces.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Celebrate the 15th and 10th anniversary
of its TV and theatrical
anime released respectively,
EJ anime still brings you this exclusive
commemorative Ukiwe woodblock prints,
which is only available
through a reservation
until December the 25th, 2020.
So get in quick.
- Oh, that's hot.
That's hot.
- I genuinely want that.
Like I'm honestly not going to lie.
I fucking love Harvey.
- They also have the misfit
of demon King Academy
Misha neck on swimsuit version.
- [Joey] I love swimsuits
versions of this.
- From the aforementioned
summer 2020 TV animated series
titled, Oh God.
- You wanna try that Garnt?
(speaks in a foreign language)
- Yeah, you nailed it.
- Hell yeah.
EJ Anime Store brings you a figure
of the heroin Misha neck
one of the cute swimsuits.
This special set includes this bull scroll
Which you can not, oh actually.
Oh okay.
- [Joey] Oh Okay.
Oh, okay, very nice.
- That's actually a
very nice feeling, dude.
- Yeah.
- That's like the pillow you wish you had
like it was made of-
(laughter drowns out speaker)
- It's like a hotel pillow,
Connor you're right.
(all laugh)
- And don't forget the
Zackie Chan wants to...
Connor's breaking our items on camera
but the Zackie Chan wants to hang out
Hana Zackie lights, novel
light, novel cafe Asia version.
And this one has the extra
culture now you can tell.
Look at the, look at
these, breast right here.
- The little detail right here.
The little sleeve right there, right?
- The little sleeve right there.
- They know what they're doing.
They know what they're doing.
- But we also have the Strike Witches,
Yoshika Miyafuji world witches
music Fest 2019 version.
As well, which has one of the
largest fucking backgrounds
that I've ever seen on a frame.
- Yeah, your desk going to be crying.
- Yeah, you need a lot of
space on the shelf for this one
but it looks neat.
- I'm going to pretend to
have an opinion on (mumbles)
Strike witches.
Nevermind.
- I don't know what that is.
- I know what it is and I
don't have an opinion on it.
But you can get it through EJ Anime Store.
- Be sure to go check out
these items at EJ Anime Store
dot com before they become unavailable.
Link available in the description below
they have recently been adding
a variety of collectables
such as body pillows and
clothing to that collection.
So be sure to stay tuned for updates.
(mumbles)
(Connor laughs)
- What is this?
The Tommy galaxy.
- Back to the video.
- That was, you could
understand everything, right?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Did you think you were
going to talk more Japanese,
like be forced to when you moved here?
- Yeah, yeah.
(all laugh)
- You said that with
such remorse, like, yeah.
- Because, it's so, it's weird, right?
Because I think everyone
in my life expected me to
as did I, but what ends
up happening is that
I realized, okay, I work from home,
I go to a language school where
all the staff speak English
all my friends speak English.
Oh no, I stream, I speak in English.
I go to the gym, I don't talk
because who the fuck
am I going to talk to?
Unless that whole guy talks to me.
- Yeah.
The fucking massive challenge.
- Have I told that story?
I think I have, right?
- Yeah.
- So yeah, there's actually like
pretty much no time where I-
- Although to be fair I'm
kind of the same as well like-
- Right, well, how often
do you speak Japanese
people outside of business?
- Yeah, I mean,
because of COVID I haven't
been able to see my family,
like at all.
- Right, right, yeah that
as well as maybe even worse
because strangers don't
want to talk to foreigners.
- Yeah, exactly.
I mean like our neighbor, next to us,
is like really fucking cool old couple
and like every time I see them like,
I'll talk to them in Japanese, but
I always get so nervous because
the moment I start talking to them,
I can hear it in my inflection that like,
Oh no, I'm fucking like losing
touch on this shit like.
I haven't been speaking it enough.
Because I haven't been speaking enough.
Cause all, 'cause the only
time I'll ever speak is like,
with my mom, like an occasional
Skype call or fucking.
- It's weirder you live
in Japan and you're like,
you're losing.
- Yeah, I'm losing it.
So I have to, you know
I have to like consciously fucking keep
figuring out ways of like, okay,
how can I use this language?
Because if there's one
thing I don't want to lose
it's my Japanese.
- [Connor] Of course.
- Yeah, of course, of course.
And the thing about languages is that
if you don't use it, it'll get rusty.
And that's true with like my Thai as well.
- Yeah.
- Now that I'm living out
of Thailand, I'm just like,
there's sometimes I'm trying
to remember a Thai word
when I'm speaking to my mom
and sometimes I get like
the Japanese word instead
because that's something I've
been studying more recently.
It's really...
Yeah and it's weird to
think how little I can have,
how little I can use
Japanese and also live here.
You know what I mean?
'Cause you kind of
subconsciously find a way
to make it easy for yourself.
- Not going to lie the one,
actually like one thing I have
been starting to do recently
is like every time I
read Mongo or a novel,
a Japanese novel or
something I read it out loud.
Just because if I read in my head,
like of course I'm going to understand it.
But it's completely different
like reading and speaking skills
it's completely different.
- Yeah.
- So I've liked just kind of
very quietly read it to myself.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Just to remember like,
okay, that's how you pronounce that word.
- Yeah, it's like that
for me, like reading Welsh
it's like getting confusing now
because I haven't done it in a long time.
- Yeah.
- I mean, you've seen the
Welsh language, right?
It's fucking jumble of sounds.
It's like, all right fucker-
- That's why I don't understand
people who know like
fucking eight languages.
- Some people just have it, man.
It's just a capacity, right?
Like, I don't think inherently
I would ever learn more than one language
'cause I'm lazy as fuck I'll be honest.
- Yeah.
- I mean the thing is-
- But the fact I'm try to
pick up a third it's like,
fuck, my brain is like
Connor, we're really,
we're really going on limit here, man.
We're really pushing it.
- But I don't think learning
languages is hard per se.
I think it's just like,
okay, if we just all quit
YouTube tomorrow for like a year
and just focused all our time
on actually learning this language.
I feel like we'd made
like so much progress,
but what's hard about it is
trying to learn a language
and fit it within our
already current lifestyle
where we already busy as fuck.
You know what I mean?
I feel like that's the real problem
because it's like, I'm
trying to find time where
time doesn't fucking exist nowadays,
where like it takes a lot of
fucking time and dedication
to learn a language.
- And it's a long line between
being able to speak a
language conversationally
and being fluent in the language.
- The only time I've actually
gotten like able to being
get proper Japanese practice
is when we're fucking out
on the lash or something.
We're at a random bond with like
where we were fucking
pissed out of our heads
and there was just a random Japanese bloke
who's as pissed as us.
That's pretty much been
like the best language
practice I've gotten
since I've moved here.
- Honestly, yeah.
That probably is the best way to do it
because if you're like
a little intoxicated
then you're going to be less
nervous about trying out.
- Dude, I swear to God,
I speak any languages
like 10% better when I'm
drunk, except for English.
- Except English, yeah.
- Except English.
(all laugh)
- True, true.
Fuck man.
- But I mean like languages
from what I've learned is like
learning a language and learning
music or like an instrument
is the exact same part of the brain.
- [Connor] Fuck.
- Yeah.
- And they say like, it's
exact same with any instrument
or language, but the second
one is always going to
be the most difficult.
And then from the third onwards,
it just gets easier and easier and easier.
And I guess for all, for all three of us,
the advantage is that,
we already know two
languages quite fluently.
So that's why, and you guys
are learning a third, right?
So it just puts pressure on me.
I'm like maybe I should learn
a third language as well.
- I mean, it's weird
because I don't feel like
I ever learned two languages.
This is the first time
I've felt like I've learned
trying to learn actively
learn something where,
rather than just like,
Hey, this is I just knew this as a kid.
I didn't really have to think about it.
- 'Cause you don't think about it
in your head when you speak Thai or Welsh.
- Yeah, 'cause the
thing is, it's just like
it is very much like
learning an instrument,
it's just a lot of it's
like muscle memory.
- It is pure muscle memory.
I do not remember how I learned it,
I don't remember learning it.
- Yeah.
- I Just know that I've always
been able to understand it
and speak it.
- That's why I hate it
when people ask me like,
Japanese language questions.
I'm like, I don't fucking
know how I know this.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it's also like when I...
And also when you learn
a language natively
I think you learn it wrong.
You learn it locally and in a native way-
- Yeah.
- People will ask me,
some people would ask
me questions about Welsh
and I'd be like, I don't fucking know.
I just knew from speaking it.
- Yeah.
- I don't know any of the rules.
I couldn't do half of them correctly.
- Oh that's why they
say like the best way to
learn any language is to live
in the country that speaks it.
- Right, right, right.
It's, yeah, I don't know.
And I think I get a lot
of questions about like
Oh wait, wait, which
languages do Connor speak.
Well, it's 'cause like
I don't really get much
use out of Welsh.
I don't really show it
off much unfortunately
'cause it's only spoken in Wales
and one part of like South America.
- Is that really?
- There's a really small
place in somewhere in South America
where they speak Welsh like a town.
- Really?
- Weird, yeah.
Bachelor of Welsh shirtless went there
and were like, fuck it
let's just a make a town.
Let's just do it.
It's such a nice language,
it's so beautiful.
- I fucking love the Welsh language, man.
It's so cool.
- It's always fun hearing people pronounce
the names of the towns.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Isn't that, that Buzzfeed video
with like all the Welsh names
and it's fucking horrible.
- They sound as cool as they look as well.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, because like my
dad can't speak Welsh,
my mum can speak Welsh.
So my dad fucking butchers
the names and I always just correct him.
It's fine, I just want
to be an ass and like...
- Oh yeah, I do that to my
dad with Japanese as well.
And I fucking love doing it.
- Oh yeah, it's the same situation.
- Yeah, he's like, shut up son.
(all laugh)
- Going back to the whole
like trying to fit in
around your lifestyle.
There is such a big part of
me that's like, fuck man.
I wish I could just take a year
off YouTube and like do it.
- Like perfect a skill.
- Just do Japanese class five days a week.
- I've like felt that
definitely recently where
like my entire life has
just revolved around YouTube
for like the past four, five years.
And then I kind of realized
this last year, especially,
it was just like, Hey, there
are other things I can do
with my life other than YouTube
and learning Japanese is
definitely one of them,
but I've really only have time to do one
without making like substantial
progress on the other
or just like making them
almost zero progress.
- I mean this COVID situation definitely
hasn't helped considering
that's really limiting
where we can go, right?
Because I feel travel as well,
even if you're traveling with like a bunch
of like English speaking people in Japan,
you just get into, you can
put yourself into situations
where you have to
interact with the locals.
- [Connor] Right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, just travel is such a nice way
of just meeting people
and like getting to use the
language as much as possible.
Because like, I feel there's less stress
using a language you're trying to learn
while you're traveling
because at the end of the day,
you're never going to
meet this person again.
- Yeah, I would have no qualms about
like butchering Japanese to
an old lady who's selling-
- And you get fucking nervous as shit
trying to use Japanese
at your local Konbini.
Because it's like,
I'm going to see you again
probably tomorrow same time.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- And I don't want to be remembered
as like guys who can't
speak Japanese, right.
- As much as there's a part
of me that wants to do that,
I'm like at the same time
I feel like I'm enjoying
YouTube now more than ever.
I'm enjoying everything about
it and it's going so well
that it would make no sense
to like stop doing, right.
Like, 'cause taking a year off YouTube,
although I could probably
come back from it.
I probably could.
- Yeah.
- But is it worth the risk?
Like no, probably not.
I can always learn
Japanese later on in life
which sucks that I wouldn't have it now
and I would rather have it now
but I can always-
- Why not mix the two worlds together?
- I feel like-
- What do you mean by that?
- Like make some kind of YouTube content
about you learning Japanese.
- I considered that
but I thought that'd be
such a big undertaking
and I've seen language channels
and they had like drama
because they would like not
end up learning the language.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
No joke.
Like there was this video where a guy made
like an apology video.
- But it sounds like technical drama.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh God.
'Cause you know when
those videos went around
where it was like, dude
speaks 15 languages-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- You're like, well that's just absurd.
(all laugh)
But then I, sort of watching
a lot of those videos
and I found like people who were like,
their whole channel was
about them starting from zero
and then learning the language.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And there was like
drama with this one guy
because he was learning
two languages at once.
I think it was like, I
can't remember it was like,
it was very different languages as well.
And about halfway through like a year in
and he's like, you know what?
I'm quitting Swedish.
I realized that it's just
hampering my progress
trying to learn two languages at once.
- Right.
And although, it was like the,
all the comments were
like, what the fuck man?
I can believe.
- I believed in you.
- Like your Swedish was so good, man.
Why are you...
- Like, and I was like, Whoa, whoa!
- Oh my God, anything can be drama now.
- And I just thought like,
if anything, it would be a thing where,
I would be like, okay, let's
see how much I can learn
in three months doing X a week, right.
And then I would not announce it,
not make it a prop, not make
it a series just, here we go.
- Yeah.
- But at the same time, it
also is a lot of pressure
that is like, okay, I've got to worry
about making other videos
and also actually learning Japanese.
Otherwise this video is
going to be a little awkward
if it's like three months
in I learn nothing.
(all laugh)
Fuck!
- But that would be funny, right?
Like it would be like a funny conclusion
to the video as well.
- Wouldn't it though?
- I think so.
- I just wasted three months of my life
and I learnt nothing.
- I did it for good content though.
- Wasted 30 minutes of your
life watching this video.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I don't know, fuck dude.
- 'Cause I had this video
idea where it's like,
'cause I've always wanted to like
improve more on my Japanese as well.
So I'm like, I can't just like commit
like outside of YouTube or like outside
of what I do on all
these side projects I do
because I'm just way too busy now.
Which sucks because I
really do want to like,
hone in on my Japanese a lot more.
So I thought about like,
there's like the Kanji proficiency test.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- And I've got like,
I got like the third highest on that.
But like that was back
in like high school.
But I'm like, I wonder if I can
like go for the highest one.
- How many counters do you go?
- For the highest one?
- Yeah.
- I believe it's 3000.
And I think only 0.4% of
the population has it.
Yeah, it's very like prestigious.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But I thought like what
if I did a video where I-
- Is there a Kanji for cultural cons-
- I guarantee there is, yeah.
There's a Kanji for
everything man, don't worry.
But I thought to myself, like,
I wonder if I did a
video where I just like
dedicated like a year
to just document myself
like learning that and trying
to attempt for the test.
- But isn't that scary though,
because what if you
don't make any progress
like six months in.
- That's the only thing
that's stopping me.
- That is like fuck.
- And it's also like in order for me,
in order for this video to be successful
I've got to fucking grind this shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And if I do this and
then the video flops,
then that's just like,
cool, I wasted a year of my life
for a flopped video and
a test that I failed in.
- I think unlike the
actual Japanese language,
I think you actually can like
game-ify and speed run Kanji.
Like I think Kanji is speed runnable.
- I don't know man.
- It is.
Dude, totally.
- Explain, explain.
- Explain.
- Because you can, this
there's like little apps
that will like fucking whip
you if you get it wrong, right.
So I I've speed learned
like 100 Kanji in like a day by doing that
and I know all of them now I can use them.
- But if I sat you down and
told you to write it out,
could you?
- Write it out, some of them.
- Right, that's the thing.
- Or read them.
But I mean, Japanese-
- Oh, and read them.
Would you be able to read a
hundred Kanji if I showed you?
- A hundred percent,
- Really?
- A hundred percent.
- Okay, now I'm tempted.
Now I'm tempted.
- Challenge,
challenge accepted.
- I'm tempted to do it.
- We do a live stream.
We'll both stream, you could fucking do-
- Yeah, yeah, and I'll
do a Kanji test on you.
- The basic Kanji?
- The hundred Kanji you know.
I'll do a test.
- A hundred percent we'll do it.
- Okay, okay.
- Easy.
Because-
- Sounds like a video already.
(all laugh)
- Because right, you can gamify it like,
and then you can start
picking up patterns.
And I feel like the way
that you can, I don't know.
At least when I was, when
I was learning Kanji,
I could easily pick up Kanji like I guess,
'cause especially living in Japan, right?
Because it wasn't like,
living in the UK, sorry.
Where will you learn this Kanji
you would leave your house,
you wouldn't see it.
When you leave your house in Japan,
even if you didn't talk to anyone
you see the Kanjis everywhere.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So you could keep practicing
because you keep seeing
them like, Oh, I know that.
Oh, I know that.
- Yeah, you do do that
after like every like
Trash Taste session we
be catching the train,
you'd be like, what's that sign say?
I've seen that one before.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But I feel like that's how though
that's the way you got to do it, right?
- [Connor] Right, right, right.
- 'Cause that's how a kid learns
just like through quizzes differently.
- Yeah.
- Problem is, is where it starts getting
into like this four
Kanji with four different
or the same Kanji with like
10 different pronunciations.
And it's like, oh, oh, this is-
- Which is like 30% of all Kanji. (laughs)
- I love the ones with
like two I'm like nice.
Question for you boys,
'cause we've been living
here for a year now.
How long do you think
you'll be staying here for?
- That's the question
I want to ask you too.
- What's my five-year plan? (laughs)
- Chris Broads is a fucking liar.
- Yeah.
- Chris Broads said he
wasn't going to live here
for like five years and he's still here.
Motherfucking liar.
- He's been here for eight years I think.
- What a fucking liar.
- I mean, I'm approaching my fifth year.
- I mean, time just moves fucking fast,
it doesn't even feel like
I've been here a year.
I thought, yeah, I'll live
here for like two years max,
I'm halfway through, I'm just like,
I've hardly even spent
any time and I feel like-
- Yeah, right, yeah.
That's the thing.
And like I always thought
to myself, I'm like,
I thought about it I was like,
Oh my God, I've been here
for almost five years.
- Five year old.
- Like, since I moved out and moved out
of my parents and like actually
leaved in Japan on my own.
I was like, it does feel like five years
Which is why, like, the question of like,
what do you see yourself
doing in five years?
It's starting to sound
less and less absurd to me
because back, you know
when I was in my teenage
years, the people were like,
where do you see yourself in five years?
Like five years is so far.
- You've be doing something
fucking different every year.
- Yeah.
- Back at that age.
But now it just feels like
it's you can have like a-
- Difference-
- Routine and monotonous.
- Now we just sound old, man.
(all laugh)
- We are, man, we are.
- Depending on how long
a big fucking question mark obviously is,
how long will Geex+ allow
us to be here because we're-
- Yeah, Meilyne.
I'ma calling you out right now.
- How long?
- So I'm going to say,
I'm going to say this louder.
So it all depends on how
long Geex+ will be around
because our visa depends on Geex+.
- [Meilyne] No, no, it
depends on Trash Taste.
(Garnt laughs)
- Wow.
- This (indistinct) takes
so many fucking sponsors
by the way, we can give Geex+ money.
- So that we can susciate
how fucking like loads.
- Overloads.
How many sponsors can we fit?
10 an episode.
Say no more.
- Doable, doable.
- Man, I mean-
- But I mean, like the question though,
I think, and this is kind of
goes back to the root of it all
having been here for a year,
are you guys enjoying it?
- Yeah.
There's been, I think I flip flop a lot
in the first six months.
The first six months I was like,
I would have one week
where I'm like, I hate it,
I plan to go back in two months.
- Yeah.
- I obviously not.
You know what I mean?
Like there's some weeks where
I think especially where,
and I said this in my video about my...
'Cause I made a video about
one year living in Japan.
- Yeah.
- I think the big point I
tried to mention was like
you have to make like,
you have to force yourself
to like actively go out your
way to make friends here.
- Yeah.
- It is not a country where
friends just come along.
You don't just bump into
people and you're like,
Oh, let's hang out.
It's like, you act like you
have to go out of your way
to do the whole, like, when are you free?
What's your calendar like,
let's make the solid,
not a bullshit thing.
Let's do it otherwise,
I'm not going to see anyone for two weeks.
Expect for you guys, right.
And like having this podcast
has really helped because
before it was like, okay,
we might hang out every day
but then we also might not see each other
for like a week and a half.
And then I realized I haven't
left the house in four days,
fuck, I'm starting to feel lonely.
And I live alone
and I've never lived like alone, alone.
- We've always had a
roommate or something.
- I've always had a roommate or something.
And I didn't realize like how
much I like relied on that
to like kind of keep me a little bit sane.
- Yeah.
- Because you know sometimes
my fucking roommate
Xina, I love you but yeah.
You fucking, you drive
me up the wall, right.
But that's not, that's
also not like her fault,
it was like just a thing of life.
- That comes with just having a roommate.
- Eventually you just, you
live with someone long enough
you're like, I fucking hate
just a little thing that you do.
And I have no idea why and
I thought I can live alone.
And then I like one week
into living alone I'm like,
fuck, it's quiet in here, right.
Jesus!
- I was so fucking depressed
when I started living alone here.
Like before Archie moved in
with me, I was like, fuck man.
I haven't been out of
the house in two weeks,
I'm so fucking lonely right now.
And like-
- Oh my.
Am I the only true introvert here?
(all laugh)
- I like my time alone,
don't get me wrong.
I like my time alone.
But there's only so much
time I like alone. (laughs)
Before I'm like, I require
the touch of a human skin.
- Oh, no.
I'm the same.
'Cause I remember before I moved to Japan
I basically lived alone for
like three four months.
Because Sydney was in America at the time
and we were sorting out
our visa stuff with Japan.
So that was just like, like
a fair few month period
where my only social life would be
when we be able to like
hang out in London.
And I don't know if it's just because
I've been in a relationship
for like four years,
it was just like nice having,
like just living alone
and just seeing friends
and seeing people when I wanted to,
because I guess the big
difference between Japan
and when I was living in England is that
I could see someone whenever
I wanted to in England
if I really wanted to,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, you could just message me
and we could just hang out.
- Yeah, exactly.
Exactly, I feel like
if it was the case of,
I don't know when I'm
going to see someone next
then I would be a way more lonely-
- That's why I'm like constantly
just like filling in plans
like ahead of time just being like, yo,
you want to hang out?
You want to hang out?
Otherwise you're going to find
yourself in this kind of like
dead space of just no
interaction whatsoever.
- Yeah, because like
when I first moved here
and I didn't really have
anything in my house
and yeah I was just going on Tinder dates,
just because I was lonely.
- Yeah.
- I didn't, like, it sounds
so sad but what I did-
- I didn't think people could do that man.
- And when I didn't have anything to do
I would just go to your house.
But then I felt bad, you know?
'Cause I didn't want to go
to their house every day.
- No, that's fine.
- I know you didn't
mind, but I also didn't,
like I felt like I was intruding.
- Right.
- So,
and it was just sad, you know?
And it took me a while to get used to it
and getting used to being alone.
Fuck, that sounds so sad.
(Garnt laughs)
No, I mean living alone, sorry.
Not being alone. (laughs)
- I just have to get used
to just being in my soul-
- Just crying.
- Just crying like it.
- No, I've I figured it out now.
I figured out how to have a
healthy balance of everything.
But it took me a while
because I wasn't used to it.
I always had someone in my house
that I could always be like,
yo, you want to watch TV?
You know?
- So is this your subtle way of asking us
to come house more often?
(all laugh)
- No, no, no.
- Please.
- So like, okay.
So we're going back to
our original fucking topic
of this video of like online
friends and everything.
- [Connor] Okay.
- When did you guys
realize that online friends
just wasn't enough?
They couldn't feel that whole,
that having real physical
friends that you can see, like...
- After I had like a really
healthy friend group I think.
- An IRL friend group?
- Yeah.
- Yeah after you have
like an actually good
IRL friend group that like, you just,
you would rather hang out
with more than like anyone.
I feel like there's no going back.
- Yeah, yeah.
I feel that as well.
'Cause I found like my first
proper true friend group,
like at the age of like 23, 24
that's when it kind of started.
And I remember like my mom had
like up my entire perception
because my mom had raised
me for like 18 years
to be like, don't give a shit
about your high school friends
that your real friends for life,
your actual real friends
will come in university.
So I go to (clears throat)
I go to university and
I'm just there with like
my housemates, my course
mates I'm just looking around
and I'm just like I
hate everyone around me.
(all laugh)
- You're like Michael Zlasky's just like,
where are the friends?
- Yeah, you're just like,
Mom?
Why would you lie to me, mom?
Why would you lie to me?
So, yeah, I'm not in
contact with like anyone
from like my university days.
Like some more so in my high school days
where the university was
just, university was just
like a fucking cesspool where I was.
- I definitely have more in contact
with my high school friends
than I do my uni friends.
Like not to say I don't
have any uni friends,
like I've, you know, some of
my uni friends are fucking
best friends forever, but-
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah, I don't know like,
I think that whole thing of like,
Oh don't worry about high school
'cause they won't be a friends for life.
I think that's kind of bullshit.
- Yeah.
- I think you'll you'll know
if you've made a friend for life.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I think so.
I think so.
- There is no designated time
when you will make friends for life,
it will happen along the way.
But I remember like finding
my first friend group
and now I was just realizing,
Oh, so I don't have to pretend to be
someone likable to be around you guys
'cause you guys just kind of
liked me for the person I am.
And that was just like,
so mind blowing for me.
- What the fuck is that all about?
(all laugh)
- I know.
- It's like having friends
that are like, just like,
even though there's like a
lot of people it's just like,
everyone's there to help each other.
Like if you're having a low point.
- It's the whole philosophy
of God, you're a con,
but I love you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, is that
- Yeah, and just like mates
that are just there for you.
Like, regardless of like, what's going on.
Like, and I really,
really, really value that.
And it's a shame as well because
I fucking hate texting so much.
I absolutely despise texting.
- Yeah, same here.
- And I pretty much
the only people I text,
are like people I know that
I'm going to meet up with
that I'm like, yeah.
When we meet out what's happening?
Like or it's like business or anything.
But outside of that,
I avoid it like the plague
because I just hate it.
- Why do you hate it?
- It doesn't feel genuine.
And it takes so long.
It's like, I'd rather
have a 30 minute call
than text for like a
whole day back and forth.
- All right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Same here.
Like, I mean, I'm sure you both know
I'm fucking awful at replying-
- Oh Garnt is fucking worse bro.
- And that's because like,
for me it takes like so much
mental energy to like be on it-
- I get it, I get it.
- And look at notifications.
I just have to like have a dedicated time
when I check messages, otherwise one,
I just get distracted
from whatever I'm doing.
And I much rather, I value
so much having like a
just an in-person or like an in voice
like actual communication,
because there's so much
that I can't communicate when it's just
during texts that I just
rather talk to people.
- That's true.
I feel that so much.
- No, I get that, I get that.
- I feel like
a lot of context is almost
lost as well when you're
just texting as well.
- Yeah.
- It can't be like all the
emotions can't be like,
portrayed properly.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and I kind of realized as well
that the friends you'll have in life,
the ones that like, I
might not text right now.
- Yeah.
- Like the real friends are the ones where
it doesn't matter.
I don't fucking need to text them.
- Yeah.
- Like even for a year or two.
But when I go back, I have nothing-
- And it's exactly.
It's exactly the same.
- Yeah.
- It's exactly the same.
The way I see it is like,
it's kind of like a family reunion.
You know what I mean?
And I didn't fully understand the term
where it was just like friends
are the family you choose
until I had a proper friend group.
Yeah, I was just like,
I remember hearing that
for like my entire life and
thinking that's such a bullshit.
(all laugh)
That's like this like cheesy Disney movie,
(indistinct) that isn't actually real.
It's a fucking urban myth.
It's a fucking urban legend.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- It wasn't the destination,
it was the friends that
I made along the way.
(harmonizes)
- So, with that being said
back to the question at hand
which was, how long are you
gonna stay in Japan for?
What do you think?
What do you think boys?
'Cause I think right now
my main thing is that like
at the end of the day, with
all my gripes that I had
and I I've made them very known,
as the comments like to point out
that they think I despise Japan.
- No.
- I'm very critical to everything in life.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And at the end of the day, Japan,
the standard of living is just
much higher at the moment.
- Especially when you're British
you just learn to complain
about all the little.
- Yeah, a lot of people just think that
I really see a lot of comments like,
Connor's so fucking rude about Japan.
Like, no I'm just British.
- No, it's just being real, bro.
It's just being real.
- It's just being British.
- There's no perfect
country out there man.
- We complain about everything.
And, okay, here's the
question to you guys.
So, we all are living in the place
that is not where we were born.
Did you always know that you would move
out of your home country
and live somewhere else?
- Yeah, absolutely.
'Cause like, at least for me,
I moved out of the house
that I was born in.
- Yeah.
- So I never moved until
I moved out of my home.
So I've been living in that,
what, like my parents' house
for late 21 years straight.
And I was just like, yeah, it's home
but it's also like, you know, you go home
and you just see the same view
out of the window every day, right.
I need something else.
- I love my home, don't get me wrong.
But I think, especially
because I was so active online
from such a young age, I
became so like globally.
- Of other different places.
- Right, right, right.
- Right.
- And then it just made
me curious I guess.
I remember, yeah.
Going back to my fucking mom, it was just,
I remember like when I was
a kid, I was just like,
mom, I'm telling you
this now love England's
but I'm going to move out.
- Three-year-old Garnt.
- No, seriously.
I was like, you know
between like when I was like going
from a kid to a teenager,
I fucking knew that I would like
move out of England eventually.
And I was like, mom, don't
take this personally.
I'm just going to move out.
I'm not going to be in the country
and mum was like, sure, sure bet, bet.
(all laugh)
Okay, son whatever you say.
And then I remember when I told her,
Hey mom, I'm just going
to like fucking move
to Thailand for a few years.
She was like, surprised Pikachu face.
Like, (gasps)
Like, Oh, you, you were actually
serious all of these years.
And yeah, because like,
not that I don't love England, but one,
I wanted to experience
like different cultures
and everything since I was a fucking kid.
And two like, I don't know, I was always,
in my head I was always thinking that
there was this perfect place to live.
That wasn't the place that you were from
because everywhere else
seems so exotic right
and everything.
And like the more I move
around, the less idea
I have about where I truly
want to fucking settle down.
It's really weird, right?
Because especially if you live like
stay in a place for like any
substantial amount of time
you see all the great things
that are there and you
also see the bad things.
There's no fucking perfect place.
And the more you move around
the more you realize
there is no perfect place.
So where you got to make
that decision of, Hey,
what is actually best for me.
- Legit one, between the
ages of like 12 and 16
I thought America was the perfect place.
- I thought America was.
- I really wanted to live in America
like all my life until like age,
probably actually until
like I moved to Japan.
I still like, before that, I was like
I kinda just don't want
him to go to America, man.
I don't know.
Always since a young age,
I'd always been exposed
to American culture.
I always spoke with Americans online
and I just really loved
their style of doing things.
- Yes.
- I loved how fucking crazy they are.
- I don't know.
I think it's because for me
it's like, I didn't really like
interact with any Americans.
- I think that's the thing, right?
Because like, literally from age 12
I've been chatting to people online,
always voice chatting like,
my parents, for some
reason didn't stop me.
(laughs)
- All you did was random Americans.
- And most of the online friends you got
were just from America, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah a lot of them were.
Yeah.
- A lot of the people
you were friends with
were from America so-
- And I was the token British
friend, most of the time.
They were like, it's fucking Connor.
(screams)
(speaking simultaneously)
- No, we were cool back then.
- Yeah, we were.
That was when we were respected online.
- Yeah.
- God, I miss those days.
Now it's all fucking memes
and bad teeth and shoes day.
YouTube.
- YouTube innit.
- This video is sponsored by Mack Weldon.
- When it comes to
holiday gifting for guys,
I'll admit it's not
necessarily my strong suit
but that's where Mack Weldon comes in.
Now thanks to Mack Weldon,
it's super easy and simple
to find something great
no matter which guy you're shopping for,
whether you're shopping for
yourself or for the boys.
- Hell I am.
- The boys is all that matters.
You can get everything from Mack Weldon's,
men's essentials, socks, shirts, hoodies,
underwears, polos, and active shorts.
(all laughs)
- Hey, I have the active shorts Garnt,
don't clown about them.
- Do you have the active shorts?
- I actually do, I wear
them to the gym Garnt.
Mack Weldon has men's basics
that are guaranteed to
keep everyone on your list comfortable.
Like this sweater that I wear
when I'm feeling lazy at home.
Thank you, Mack Weldon.
- And this t-shirts, which,
just look, look at how
breathable this t-shirt is
look at it.
Perfect for the gym, which
is where I wear it to
when I go to the gym
once a year, apparently.
- And Joey's mask.
- And my mask, which I wear
everywhere to keep myself safe.
- That's why Mack Weldon
makes the perfect gift.
I also have the Sunday
lounge pants at home,
which I didn't bring with me because
there are stains and shit all over them
because I don't leave the
house when I wear them
because they're so damn comfortable,
I just can't get out of the house.
But they also look pretty stylish too.
- Mack Weldon looks great and feels great
from working out, going out,
going to work or on a date,
Mack Weldon is for everyday life.
- And all Mack Weldon
stuff comes in a wide range
of customized fabric
that keeps up with you
no matter what your day looks like.
- [Connor] 18 hours silver,
all and it's dryness,
warm too many goddamn
nets that's for sure.
- [Joey] Plus you can
check out Weldon blue
which is they're totally
free loyalty program.
Level one gets you free shipping for life
and once you reach level
two, by spending $200
you get 20% off every order
for the next 365 days.
- But boys, you can't forget about the
Mack Weldon guarantee.
- Tell us about the Mack Weldon guarantee.
- I thought you would never ask gentlemen.
Mack Weldon wants you to be comfortable
so if you don't like your
first pair of underwear
you can keep them and
they'll still refund you.
No questions asked.
- That is very generous.
- It very much is.
- I would have thought
Mack Weldon would have
wanted me to send him
back to the underwear
but they're just letting me keep it.
- They're just like, nah bro keep it.
- They can only imagine the heinous shit
you've done in those
after watching the hentai
episode of Trash Taste.
But, we're in the gift giving season
and get 20% off your first order,
visit mackweldon.com/trashtaste
and enter promo code trashtaste.
That's mackweldon.com/trashtaste
and use the promo code
trashtaste for 20% off.
Mack Weldon re-inventing men's basics.
I fucking nailed-
- TM, thank you to Mack Weldon
for sponsoring this episode
back to the video.
- Yeah, the more I think about it
the more is kind of fucking weird
that I did speak to like
just anyone like online.
- I would never let my kid do that.
I don't know why I did it.
- Your parents were just cool with it.
Were your parents aware of it?
- No, I didn't tell them.
I would just tell my mother
that I was talking to my friend.
They're like, who you who...
'Cause okay.
So when I used to swear, right?
So I lived, I lived.
My room is upstairs, right.
So whenever I swore too loud
and my parents heard it,
I would hear this at the stairs.
(taps desk)
And like, Connor! Stop swearing!
Because my dad swore a bunch, right.
But he tried not to around
me but I fucking I was,
I could not stop swearing over an Xbox.
- Yeah, cause you're that
one angry kid on Xbox.
- Because right, if you wanted any credit
as a 13 year old, you had to curse, man.
Come on.
You gotta talk shit.
- I mean, I can't relate.
- Have you ever given any
13 year old kid credit
now that you're in the opposite end?
- Yeah.
- If they shout.
- Yeah, right.
(Garnt laughs)
- Of course not.
But when you're that age,
I hate to be a bit fat.
Okay, British Xbox is a different beast
or whatever the you had, dude.
It was 'cause everyone in these
lobbies was like 13, 14, 15.
- Now that sounds like these-
- No, no, no that sounds
like every Xbox lobbies.
- And so half the games,
I would enjoy the fucking game more
'cause I was fucking screaming at someone.
Then for some reason I enjoyed-
- You were legit that one squeaker.
- No, I wasn't...
I mean, okay.
Was I squeaking then?
Maybe I was squeaking.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Who knows?
- [Garnt] Right.
- You were a cold squeaker.
(laughs)
- Yeah, God!
(Joey laughs)
My God!
- See, don't VA confirmed called squeaker.
- Oh my God, that was so funny.
So many dumb, so much
dumb shit I did on Xbox.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
- So here's the question
now then, now that we've,
now that you've like gone
to Japan and gone to America
and these are like the two places
you really like, kind
of like fantasize about
when you were younger,
is there any place in the world
that you still want to go to
or is it all just like-
- Yeah, what's on everyone's
like country bucket list?
- Or is it all just downhill from here?
Like I've been everywhere I want to,
there's nowhere else I want to go.
- Okay, man.
(all laugh)
Not really.
Here's the thing, right?
Because people like
say, I want to go here,
I want to go here like,
there's some countries, people like,
I really want to go here.
I'm like, why?
Why the fuck would you want to go there?
They're like-
- Like where?
(all laugh)
- I'm not going to name any names.
- Just take a sample.
- This is going to sound
fucking terrible, right.
There are some countries right,
where it's like, not going to lie.
If I want to vacation somewhere,
I want to know that I can
shit in a clean toilet.
Okay, I'm just going to say, right?
Is that a bad thing?
Am I allowed to say that?
- That's a very privileged thing to say.
- That's hella privileged.
I know it is.
But at the end of the day,
I'm just going to be honest.
I don't want to fucking shit
in the hole in the ground, man.
It's too much.
- Okay, no it's,
you never get used to it.
(all laugh)
Have you ever had to use the
hole in the ground toilet?
- Yeah, in France I had to and
I thought this was a
fucking civilized country.
What is this?
I don't know.
Okay, this is like-
- I used to go camping so much
so like shitting in a hole
was just normal for me.
- Because, right, I spoke to Allen.
- Yeah.
- And I'm sure when he
comes on the podcast,
he can tell about it.
He can tell the stories about how his dad
forced him to go to Kenya on holiday.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- And he made it sound
like it was fucking hell.
And I'm like, why the
fuck would I want to go
on vacation there?
When everything sounds horrible?
Like what?
Like, if I vacation, all
I want to do is just relax
and just chill out.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I don't want to fucking do activities.
I don't want to fucking ride camels.
I don't want to fucking be uncomfortable.
- Everyone-
- You sound like my granddad.
(all laugh)
- Honestly, I'm already
accepted that I am like
a 60 year old white dude
when it comes to holidays.
- Like, you just don't
want to like adventure-
- I don't wanna.
- In another country, right?
- I don't either.
I'm a hundred percent with Connor on this.
- I'm fine with doing an
activity on a day or two,
maybe we can hike but
I do not want to fucking
do shit every day.
I also don't want to have to like just-
- I don't want to have pressure
that I need to go see something.
- [Connor] Yes.
- If I'm in a place and I'm
just like you need to go here,
you need to go there,
you need to see this,
I'm just like, I hate it already.
Like, I will go to one cool place
and it's just like, I've
seen enough, I'm satisfied.
Can I just go home
and just like fucking
enjoy a pint or something.
But that's my perfect holiday.
- And it doesn't come from a place of,
maybe it does come from
a place of privilege.
I don't fucking know.
Probably it does.
But I honestly don't give a fuck.
I just want to chill on my holidays.
- I think it was just 'cause of like
what I went through as a kid.
'Cause when you go on
holiday as a kid, right?
You got to follow what everyone else says.
- Right.
- I always like had this fucking
especially if I go into like a big group,
like this start fucking itinerary.
Where all I wanted to do was
just stay in my fucking hotel
room and play my Nintendo DS.
That's all I wanted to
fucking do on holidays.
- Because we used to, I
used to go camping in France
like I said, every year for three weeks,
right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And most years I fucking hated it.
And my parents thought that I
was just like, they thought...
Okay, I get it now what
they think, they're like,
Oh, he's just saying he hates it.
You know what I mean?
Like that's what parents think.
No, I actually-
- He's just a (indistinct)
- No, I actually hated it.
It was like, you were in a tent,
you were sleeping on the floor.
It was uncomfortable.
So it's like three weeks,
you're eating the same shit.
Like everything is-
- [Joey] Okay, to be fair-
- Everything is grilled on a barbecue.
- I love camping don't get me wrong.
I used to like, my dad
used to take me camping
like in the fucking Australian
Outback all the time.
But it wasn't for three weeks,
it was like tops, like five days.
- That's the thing, right, I think those-
- Three weeks is way too long.
- I think that was like
has completely put me off
vacationing in any places
that aren't just like,
honestly, just like relaxing in a nice bed
and just eating nice food.
Like that kind of like put me off for life
because I spent most
of my childhood summers
just sleeping on the floor,
eating everything that had to be grilled
because that's all you had to cook, right.
It was a grill, eating baguettes nonstop.
And then always there's
horrible public showers
that are never clean.
And then sometimes you would see like
piss in the corner and
it would always smell
and it was just awful.
Like everything was awful.
And even as a 12 year
old, I could be like,
is this some peasant joke?
I'm too rigid to understand.
I just, I don't know.
Like, I would just be like-
- That would turn me off as well.
- I would always be like,
at home we had a toilet
that was nice and it didn't
stink of just everything.
Why does it here?
- Yeah.
- I also wonder how
different my perceptions
of a lot of these activities would be
if I actually went nowadays.
- Now I would love with my mates.
- With my mates because-
- But not for three weeks. (laughs)
- No, no, no.
- Part of the reason I like
looked back and dread about it
is because you spent it with,
you were forced to be there
with like your family and something
and you wanted to do something else
that your family didn't want to do.
And I feel like that's just like
that kind of memory has
been ingrained into me
that I just like, I hate this activity
because I did that shit
as a kid and I hated it.
- Yeah, because my parents
were obsessed with like
maximizing the fuck out of the day.
Like it was like, let's go...
If we got in France, it's like,
yeah, let's just walk
around this town all day.
And I'm like, fuck no.
I want to go to the arcade all day.
(Garnt laughs)
I don't want to walk all day.
Like I'm still at the age
where walking just hurts.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
(Connor laughs)
- All day, right?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know.
Like for some reason
when you're a kid like
walking long distances, just doesn't work.
- Or like, were you an active kid?
- A hundred percent.
Like I was doing sports
two, three times a week.
- [Joey] Oh okay, okay.
- But for some reason-
- Just walking is yeah.
- When I had to walk all day,
it was just pain.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- It was just pain, man.
- Pain.
- [Connor] And then like-
- Pain pickle.
- And then when you're a kid, right.
There's nothing more boring than fishing.
I would have to do it.
- That's true.
- And I thought-
- I'm glad my dad never
got me into fishing.
Like my dad fucking despised fishing.
- It's something that I
could see me enjoying now
with a mate and drinking a few pints.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've actually been fishing
for the first time recently
which was like two years
ago with Sydney's dad
and Sydney's a brother took
me fishing for the first time.
I actually really fucking enjoyed it.
- Right, as an adult.
- It's one of those
things that like as a kid
you're just not wired to do it.
- Okay, okay.
There...
(laughs)
This is going to make me sound so bad.
But there is one big difference
about why I can enjoy it now
versus why I couldn't enjoy as a kid.
And that's because
alcohol is now involved.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(all laugh)
I have never seen a man fish
with not a beer in that little pocket.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It doesn't happen.
- Because I mean, you had,
it's not part of the charm.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like going in as a kid
it is just like, it's the ADHD simulator.
Because all you want to do is like
why is there not fish
catching on this immediately?
Oh, I'm trying to get this
fucking thing on the thing
and my, fucking.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Where's my Nintendo DS,
I need to fucking play cooking
mama for 20 minutes to relax.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You trying to do it and nothing happens,
you get shit fish.
And as a kid, you're like,
let's kill it and eat it.
- Let's just do something.
- Let's fucking decapitate this fish.
And then is that your dad's
like, we threw back in.
I'm like, what's the point?
I want to eat it.
(all laugh)
Because you're a kid and you
think in every video game.
I've caught it and I've eat it.
Why are you stopping me dad?
- It's the worst activity for a kid.
- It doesn't make sense
and just the whole thing
just completely ruined, like
doing that kind of stuff
for me as an adult now
because I have just no interest.
- Yeah.
I would actually go back
fishing with my mates
because it was just like
a nice male bonding sesh.
- We should go fishing.
- I would be happy to go
fishing with you boys.
- I haven't been fishing
in for like five years.
- I will tell you what,
because I've had this image
of what fishing would
be like my entire life.
And because like my only
experience with fishing
my entire life has been through
the fucking fish and mini games you get in
every fucking Zelda game or every
like it's in animal crossing, whatever.
- You can play for the free controller.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And I thought to myself
there's no way it's going to be like this.
And I was fucking surprised
at how accurate that simulation is.
Like, it literally felt
like a controller rumble
and I'm just like, Oh,
like, this is just like
the fucking video games.
- And you're just like, where's the a bus?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's literally just instead
of tapping the a bus
and you just go (hisses)
And yeah.
But for some reason it was just like,
it was very therapeutic
and if you like fishing mini games,
it's exactly like that
and I was surprised, man.
- Every like fishing enthusiast
is just like frothing at the mapping
like how fucking dare he say that?
- Man, yeah, I don't know, man.
I just it's completely like,
so to answer your question
Joey, oh God, sorry.
No, I think there's not
many any other countries
that I'm like desperate to go.
Obviously I've never been to any of Asia,
so I really want to explore a lot more.
- [Joey] Hmm.
- Yeah.
Like there's so many activities
that I like the idea of.
Like, I like the idea of
camping, you know what I mean?
The idea-
- Two days, two days, max.
- It's charming.
- The idea sounds cool
until you fucking wake up and it's like,
the fucking worst thing I
hate is when you wake up
and everything it's just dump
you feel things and it's dump
and dump is like the
worst fucking climate.
Everything's damp and
moist and I'm depressed
and it's cloudy and I'm
just like, why am I here?
I chose to be here, this
is supposed to be relaxing.
- Oh dude, then you should
come camping in Australia, man.
It's like fucking dries in there all year.
- Yeah, but than everything
wants to fucking kill you
and I have something else to worry about.
- Only if you go out and
fuck with the animals,
don't fuck with the animals
and they'll leave you alone.
- 'Cause camping in the UK is just
either fucking cold as
shit or just damp as fuck.
- Oh, not gonna lie camping in the UK
sounds fucking horrible.
- Right.
- I mean, because we have to do a thing
in the UK called like,
Oh, you don't have to
do it, it's optional.
Duke of Edinburgh, did you do that?
- My sister did that.
- No.
- Yeah, where you basically
like have to do a bunch
of things to get a fucking stupid award-
- Like go out camping and
hiking and shit, yeah.
- And they always told you in school,
it's like, you should get it because
it's going to look amazing
when you apply for jobs
and no one-
- No one cares.
- No one cares, no one cares.
And on it like, yeah,
you have to do like a hiking
slash camping thing where you
do two days of like full hiking
with like the big bags and then camp.
This is going to sound
like so fucking stupid
but I was the only one who was
like, I'm bringing a pillow.
I want to be comfortable when I sleep.
- The privileged white boy.
- No, no.
So I big brained it, right.
Because all these kids
brought like dumb shit, right.
And we had to, we brought like
a stove to cook on as well.
We were like 16 as well so,
I brought the pillow, right?
And as I was sleeping,
they'll start fucking
trying to take it from me.
(Joey laughs)
'Cause they were sleeping
on the hard floor
with a t-shirt rolled up and I'm like,
no, no, no, no, no.
I'm the one who was the stupid
dick who carried this pillow all the way
for like eight hours.
(all laugh)
This is my pillow.
- This is my reward.
- And I woke up and one of
them had fucking took it.
And I woke up on the thing
covered in fucking dampness.
And I was like, Oh my God
did it rain bear in mind,
this is the three person
tent, with four of us in it.
And I woke up, being like oh my God!
it must have rained so much.
I go outside, it's completely dry.
And I'm like, Oh, it was sweat!
It was all sweat!
It was all condensation.
(screams)
- Yeah, 'cause my sister
did Duke of Edinburgh
but she did like the highest level.
So she like hiked-
- It's like a week, right?
- Yeah, she hiked across Vietnam twice.
- What?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I-
- Why would you want to do that?
- I don't know.
She did it twice though.
- I did two days and I was like,
I think, no, this isn't for me.
I'm going to go back to sitting on the bed
and watching anime.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I think that, I just..
This isn't for me.
- Why did you even decide to do it?
- Well, because it's one of
those things where it's like,
I can do it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- If you ask me to go hiking
for a week, I'll do it.
I'm very capable of doing it.
- [Joey] Right.
- I just hate every second of it.
- Well, then why do you accept it?
- All my parents were
like, you should do it.
And I was like fine, okay, okay.
And I was doing the other
stuff anyway, because
I was teaching kids
chess at my old school.
- Okay.
I don't know man, like
I knew from the get-go
when like the option was brought
up of dude, would you like
to do Duke of Edinburgh?
Would you like to go hiking
and fucking experience
dampness for a week straight?
I was like, no.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- No, of course I don't.
- I think because it's wild,
they wanted like the kids who had
a lot of experience camping
to help the kids who hadn't done any.
And I was only like,
there was only like three
or four boys and like the
boy Scouts in like my year
and then there was like me
who done a lot of camping.
So it was like, okay.
- So you were the experience camper.
- I guess, yeah to me it was like,
Connor should help out and join.
- You were the boy scout, right?
- I never did any like map
direction or anything like that,
my parents fucking did all that.
And I barely helped with
setting up the tents.
(laughs)
- You just put the bag down.
- I used to be like, Oh, I'm
gonna go play with the Frisbee.
(all laugh)
So when we did it, I do
remember this as well.
Like when it came, I was
like, I'll do the cooking,
you can set up the tent.
'Cause setting up the tent is...
And it's 'cause it was one
of the cheap ones as well.
And the cheap ones are like, (laughs)
connect the 576 poles together.
And it's like, no, none
of them can get it right
and I'm like, I'm going to
cook the bacon that I brought.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That was yeah, I-
- I'd be down to go
camping though in Japan.
I've never been camping in Japan.
- Glamping, we should do glamping.
- Yeah, glamping is cool.
- I've never gone glamping.
- It's like camping without
all the frustration.
- It's like camping with privilege.
- It's like campling with civilization.
If we didn't want to like
invent all this shit-
- It's camping with attitude.
- We wouldn't have-
(all laugh)
- Though I'ma be real,
I don't want to camp without 4G.
Like, what's the point?
Like, I'm just gonna say it, right.
I know it's not the same,
I don't give a fuck.
I want 4G.
- I can camp without 4G.
- That's your problem.
- Okay, you know what?
I need a toilet, you're right.
Toilets-
- Yeah, toilets.
- I don't want to shit in a fucking bag
or a hole in the ground.
- [Connor] You haven't been-
- There's a reason fucking humans evolved
and invented toilets and civilization.
- Have you ever wiped
your ass with a leaf?
- No.
- It just doesn't work,
but that's all you have.
What you gonna do?
Grab a handful of grass?
No you have to use leaves
and hope that you can
just get most of it out.
It's awful.
- Well, that's why I like the one thing
we always took camping was
like a bunch of toilet rolls.
- Damn dude, 2020 man,
you fucking find some.
- Because yeah, you'd
go out into the bush,
you'd wipe yourself, put it in a bag
and then you throw all that into a fire.
- I must've been as like 12 year old me,
it was like instant
noodles or toilet roll?
Fuck dude, I mean.
- I can't eat the toilet roll.
(all laugh)
- It's chicken flavor
though, you know what I mean?
Come on, man.
(laughs)
- Chicken flavor or poopy butler.
- Oh God, it was, I do
remember when we did it,
there was awful 'cause like
it was a lot of kids that were
just not prepared at all
and had never even done any hiking at all.
And those things are heavy
and a lot of them just couldn't do it.
And you had to stay as a team
so it was like every 15 minutes
one kid would have a
fucking mental breakdown
and it was like-
- I can't do it.
- I can't hold it.
- [Garnt] And I think-
- Oh, go on go on, I have nothing to say.
- So the only thing that like
puts me off camping in Japan
from what I've seen, like,
only like the pictures
and everything that I've
seen is that it looks very,
how can I say it's commercialized.
'Cause it's like you have
this like camping spot
and like, I see a bunch of tents there.
- It's very privileged.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I'm just like-
- You're put right next to someone.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And it's just, I remember the one thing,
I remember about camping is just like
how little noise protection you have
from one tent to another, right?
You hear everything.
Right.
And especially the, what I,
especially the camping
experience I would like to have,
which is like a bonding mate sesh.
Like, I don't know,
especially if you have like
a bunch of Japanese people
around you with tents and
everyone values their privacy.
Can you imagine how
quiet you'd have to be?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Or we could just be
those like ignorant guys
and just be like,
no, one's making noise at this campsite
Well, I think we will like fuck it.
What are they going to say?
- You just hit like at 2:00 AM
just like aggressive Uno
noises like from drunk people.
(all laugh)
I don't know, man.
- Fucking Jojo Uno's session
at two in the morning in a tent.
- We should do Trash Taste hiking special.
- Oh God!
- I'd be down, man.
I used to go hiking all the fucking time.
- Do you know what the worst part is,
it's actually not a bad idea.
- Yeah.
(Connor laughs)
I'd be down dude, I'd be down.
- It's all about, I'd
be willing to do it now.
Is it for content?
Okay, I'm willing to fucking
suffer for content whatever.
(laughs)
- I am, I am, I am.
- That's the tipping point, right?
It looks like I'll do
it, but is it monetized?
(all laugh)
Yeah, all right, I'll do it.
- How did we get on talking about camping?
- I don't know.
But like, yeah.
So yeah, what the fuck
were we talking about?
Oh yeah, if you're going
to stay in Japan or not?
- Oh, well, I mean-
- Oh no, no.
It was that which country would you visit?
Like, is there a country that's
at the top of your bucket list
right now for like visiting?
- Korea.
Korea, Korea.
- Korea?
- Yeah, I really want
to go to South Korea.
- For me it's Iceland.
- Iceland?
- Yeah, I don't know.
I love everything about that country.
The language, just the
culture around I'm like,
all the places I've seen
because it's such a tiny country, right?
So it's like, if you have
a car you could fucking
and you have a week
you can probably visit
most of that country
- I do wanna go Mexico.
But a lot of people I know
who are Mexican, who are like,
yeah, its dangerous as fuck.
- Yeah, that's what I've heard.
- I'm like, Oh okay.
- Yeah.
- I really like how safe it is here.
- Exactly, exactly.
(all laugh)
- But it's like, food's amazing.
Really good time.
Just really fucking dangerous.
- Yeah, exactly.
Is there one for you?
Do you have like a bucket list of like,
I wanna go to this country.
- I mean, probably Iceland is at the top.
I do wanna really go
back to Korea as well.
I've only been there for like a few days,
but I feel like that just
wasn't enough time for me.
- Yeah, I'd love to go.
- [Connor] Thailand as well.
- And it's just throw away, right.
- I really wanna go to Thailand as well.
- Oh yeah, Thailand.
- I definitely want to go
to Southeast Asia more.
- Yeah, yeah, I want to
go to Vietnam as well.
- Have you ever been to Singapore
either or Malaysia or any,
have you ever been anywhere
in Asia except for Japan?
- Yeah.
- So I really want to be-
- See like, I want to
travel more around Asia.
'Cause I feel like there's only a few
Asian countries that
I haven't visited yet.
- 2020 psych.
- Yeah.
- Trash Taste, South Asian tour. (laughs)
- Like, I mean, I do want to
visit just everywhere really
and just make my own...
I joke and say just
that I don't want to go
to a lot of places but
I wouldn't mind going
and passing through and checking it out.
Like Egypt, I really want to go to,
Algeria I really wanna go to.
- Australia, I really
want to go to Australia.
- South Africa, I really wanna go to.
And I was joking about Kenya, but,
I'm sure I can have a nice time there
and I'm just being ignorant as fuck.
I'm sure there's going to be
comments saying that I am.
- Oh yeah, of course.
'Cause I've always thought like,
ah, I don't really want to
like visit like this place,
like Africa, for instance.
Or like the middle East
and stuff like that
but like the more I kind
of hear about those places
from people who are either from there
or just from shit you see, it's just like,
- Yeah.
- You know what?
That actually might be kind of dope.
I don't know.
But it's just, it's such a toss up though,
because there's a lot of those countries
we just hear nothing about.
- Yeah.
- And you just like,
are we hearing nothing
about it because it's bad
or because people just don't go.
- Austria is like a country
you don't hear much about,
but it's pretty nice.
I really like Austria.
- [Joey] Yeah right?
- Austria is super chill.
- You go skiing there, right?
- Yeah, I've been skiing in Austria
and snowboarding in Italy.
It's really nice.
Just skiing in Europe
or snowboarding in Europe
in general it's like,
it's super expensive,
but it's really nice.
- I really want to do it.
- It's really nice.
- Yeah, yeah.
I just want to go to Europe more.
- Yeah, everything's just
super fucking expensive.
- This is just like a travel wishlist.
This is just us
fantasizing in COVID times.
Remember before COVID existed
and we could travel to places.
- Remember when I could see my family.
(all laugh)
Yeah, I do want to go back
home and visit my family
'cause it's weird.
'Cause this will be like the second
Christmas in a row where
I haven't seen them.
Which is normally would be
the thing where it's like,
okay, I'll go back for Christmas.
All right, fuck it, you know?
But yeah, I mean, that's one big thing,
but as far as living in
Japan goes and I mentioned on
the quality of life
being really good here.
I definitely feel like at
least another two years
I want to stay here.
And I think it'll be a case of in a year,
I'll know if it's gonna
be another two years.
It's one of those things where I'll just,
as it goes, I'll keep
changing that number.
- That's how it is.
Like from like with a lot of my friends
who are from overseas who live
here or have been living here
it's always the case of,
all right, we'll give us one
more year and see how it goes.
And then usually like 90% of the time
after that year ends up, it's like,
another year?
One more year?
And then it just keeps going, right.
- And it's such a pain to move shit back.
It's like, is it really
worth the, like moving.
- I really can't be
bothered with that again.
- But do you guys feel this as well?
I don't know if you guys feel the same,
but like for me this has
been the first year where
what I do actually feels like a career
as opposed to just me
just being self-employed
doing my own fucking job that-
- I mean, I've never been
employed, up until this point so,
it just feels good.
- It just feels like
for the first time this isn't just a job,
it's like my career now.
And I don't know.
You don't think doing
like doing like YouTube
in your job the environment really matters
because you can technically do it anywhere
but the more like I've done this
and the more of like growing
up, the more I realized,
Hey, environment really fucking
matters in your workspace.
- Oh yeah.
- Like I remember going,
like I remember in university
where I'm just like,
I can do YouTube wherever.
I can do it in my fucking room.
I can do it next to my bed.
And then I suddenly realized
I need my own fucking office,
I need my own fucking space.
I need to separate,
work and my leisure time because
you can survive with it
and you can do it, but
you're just, they'll end up be a point
where you get fucking depressed
and you get tired and it's not healthy.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah and I mean, it
definitely completely changed my
productivity but also
just like my enthusiasm
towards my career and I guess like
it really cemented the
severity of what I do.
Of like this isn't just
like a little fun thing
that you get paid for.
This is your job.
Like this is your career like
putting food on the table is this now
and everything you do
revolves around this.
And definitely, like
moving to a bigger place
and getting my own like actual work room
has like really cemented that like, okay.
This is like, yeah, I
can fuck around on camera
and be silly and goofy.
- Yeah.
- But it's also my job.
Like I can't half-ass this shit,
like I need to be serious about it.
But like that's brought
on an entirely different,
I guess, layer of enjoyment
that I otherwise would
have never experienced.
And I don't know, like, I
think it's because as well
like all of the topics
that we cover of like,
the kind of otaku kind of stuff
and like anime kind of
stuff where it's like,
- Yeah.
- Doing it here as
opposed to anywhere else,
it's just, I think completely different.
- Oh, it totally is.
And like one of the biggest
things that I've like
realized this year is
a lot of the mystery,
a lot of like the
mystery and the prestige,
not the prestige, like the mystery around
like the anime industry itself
has kind of like, I see the
anime industry totally different
because I remember
before like I moved here
and you know, as a teenager,
as a kid, you think,
maybe I could like, as a dream job,
I can work in anime one time.
But like you have no fucking clue
what steps you need to take.
Like I thought you had to be
like incredibly fucking lucky
and like the more I meet people
who work in this industry
the more realized, Oh,
you just need to be here.
You know what I mean?
- You just need to be here
and know one person and that's enough.
- And sometimes you could fucking
look up a job on Craigslist.
Sometimes you just you were like
teaching English or something
and you just happen to stumble-
- You just meet a person, right?
- You just happen to stumble
upon someone who has an opportunity.
Like the biggest advice I can give now,
if you are interested in working
in the Japanese anime industry,
it's just the fucking be here.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause it's like, I've
been surprised at how
like sometimes even how
low the bar of entry is
because it's like the
bar of entry seems to be,
okay, yeah university degree
but that's like the minimum
you have to get a visa
but aside from that, it's
just kind of being here
and just hanging around the right places.
- [Connor] Definitely noticed that.
- And I didn't think,
I just didn't think it worked that way.
I thought it was just like closed off
to all kinds of foreigners
and anyone else, like-
- Or it took like years and
years of building yourself.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And we would go to those anime studios
and you just meet a guy
who's like, I'm American.
- And then you ask,
how did you get this job?
Because it was like,
you think they just had
like the craziest fucking
journey to get here.
- And then they're just like, Craigslist.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah then most of the time it's just,
yeah, I was just teaching English
and then I just saw a job
posting for a random anime job
and I just went for the
interview and I'm just like
Oh wait, it was that
easy this entire time.
Did you even speak English-
- It's literally the McDonald's method.
Of like, I see an ad,
I'll apply for it, fucking why not.
- You get the job, oh, okay.
- Oh, okay.
Oh see, I got the job, cool.
- Yeah, I don't know.
I guess totally agree
with that in terms of
all the mystique around it's kind of like
slowly peeling away, right?
- [Joey] Right.
- But yeah, I don't know.
It's hard to summarize all my feelings
about living here and working here.
But yeah, definitely the
structure has been added
and I don't know if
that's because of Japan
or because of how
we've scheduled and built
our work environment.
- Optimized.
- Yeah, I mean, having an
agency here that works with us
and works with anime
has been super helpful
and has helped me feel like a lot more,
yeah, like you said structured.
'Cause before this,
yeah, I was just kind of
fucking around I think
and I was just hoping that
the cheques kept coming in.
- Yeah, right?
(all laugh)
- I was like, I'll just keep making stuff
that I really enjoy-
- It didn't feel real, right?
- No and I assumed that every,
I assumed that every
year it could be my last.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And now I'm starting
to think, okay, well,
as long as I don't do
fucking anything stupid
- As long as none of us-
- Making an apology-
- As long as none of us get canceled.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You're probably going to be around
for a little bit, right.
You can normally safely assume
I've got a year left in
this industry, right.
Like you can probably know
we plan a year or two.
- [Joey] Right.
- And some people like, well,
like, damn, shouldn't you be working
in like getting a proper
career and whatnot?
Like, what is a proper career anymore?
Like people are still like
50 years old driving Uber's,
is that a career?
Like why people gotta make
everything about a career?
Who cares?
- It's just your
prerogative, right of like-
- Whatever makes you happy, man.
- Yeah.
If you're getting the money
and it's making you happy,
you're not hurting anybody,
I think that's a proper career.
- Yeah there's way I see
it, as well as it, like,
if for some reason YouTube falls through,
in a year and I got nothing left,
like, Hey man, I've got experiences
people could like kill for.
- Right.
All three of us have been smart enough
to kind of establish ourselves
in fields outside of YouTube.
- Yeah.
My plan B used to be go back to the BBC
and go back into engineering lifestyle.
But now like if YouTube falls through,
like I have other plan Bs
of like other businesses
I could possibly get involved in.
And that's like, it's gave
me, it's given me like
in a career that really
shouldn't have the feeling
of any kind of job security,
I do feel secure that yeah,
I do have a specific skill set that
working in doing this has given me
as opposed to five years
ago when I'm just like,
what the fuck can you learn doing YouTube?
Yeah, what the fuck can I
actually learn doing YouTube?
- I know how to edit a video.
- Like you know, when you look back
and you start doing
YouTube and you just think,
what can I possibly put on my CV?
- I'm getting the thing out of this.
- What can I possibly put on my CV, right?
- And then now you're like,
if in terms of social media
and entertainment and
marketing, it's like,
it's a big list.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- I think, you know, a
lot of people think is,
of most YouTubers as
like they're fucking dumb people.
(all laugh)
- Some college dropouts.
- I mean, you do you see a
lot of them who are like,
fuck, I'm in the same category as him.
- [Garnt] Right, right, right.
- But, I think what
people don't understand is
that they're a lot of companies that wish
they had people who
understood those kind of like,
because a lot of companies you'll see them
and they don't fucking
understand social media at all.
If we did lose our job
there was a good chance
that we could probably work in a company
and be a head of that
social media department
or help with strategizing like,
consulting anything, right?
- [Joey] Absolutely.
- I mean, it's like Dr. Disrespect, right.
He was an online creditor,
and then he went to work for,
I think, Activision, right.
Or Infinti World
and he was the head of
their community relations.
- [Joey] Oh really?
- Yeah, for a while.
- Before coming back to streaming?
- Yeah, so before he came
back, that's what he left.
'Cause he was a big cold stream I believe.
And then he left to go and be their
community management or something on-
- Social media management.
- Right, something,
I believe it was something
along those lines.
And then he came back, right.
And it speaks to even back then
that someone who had just
been doing videos online
who seems very amateurish,
that knowledge that you
gain is so invaluable
and companies wish they understood that.
And they could hire as many
teams as they want but-
- Right.
Because it's so rare
especially for someone like
Dr. Disrespect to like
reach numbers like that.
It's not something that you can like,
it's not something that it's like,
well, I got a degree and then I studied it
therefore I'm going to
get results like that.
It just doesn't happen, right?
- You learn a lot through YouTube.
And I think even if you
are doing it as a hobby now
and you don't see any potential in it,
I think the skills that you're learning
are really, really useful skills,
I don't think you realize it useful.
- Yeah, one thing,
one important skill that
I had to learn how to do
is kind of realizing what
skills I thought were useless
and were actually not useless
and it's actually
thinking back to be like,
Oh yeah, I do know how to do this thing,
maybe this is actually useful in some way.
'Cause it's like, part of
making yourself look sellable
as a person, to any employees.
What skills have you gotten,
more like experience do you have,
and like we grew up in like a generation,
or at least like, especially
with Asian parents
where we were taught,
Hey, do well in task,
get like your degree, go to university
and if you don't go to university,
you're a fucking dropout.
- Yeah.
- You're scam, you're not my child.
- And then like the older I
grew up the more I realized,
yeah, if you have like
certain career options
and certain like career paths
that you want to go down,
yes, a degree is definitely,
you definitely need that.
But if you kind of don't
know what you wanna do yet
that doesn't mean that every
other skill set you gain
is invaluable.
- [Connor] Right, right.
- You don't need a degree
to make a plan B in your life, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like, I never learned anything
about like business or marketing in school
like, I didn't take any of those classes.
I never did any of that shit in uni.
And I learned so much
about that kind of shit
just from doing YouTube.
And that's like a really
valuable skill to have
but I didn't need to go to school for it.
I just had to fucking-
- Go through it.
- Yeah, I just have to go
through it and experience it.
- Because of the way I see it, right.
I have an engineering degree.
- Yeah.
- If you put me in an
engineering workplace,
I wouldn't know fucking shit.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I don't know what's going on.
Maybe, I understand the rough concepts
that make up a lot of basic engineering
and you could probably
teach me a lot easier
but you couldn't just plop me in an office
and be like, do it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I would have no clue at all.
Because you have to
learn how that company-
- You haven't utilized that skill.
- Right, right, right.
And without using it practically,
it's like, what am I doing?
I've just got good at tests.
Like I was shit.
And I constantly got frustrated
because I never felt like
I was learning engineering.
I was learning the concept,
I felt like a lot of it was
so impractical, but I mean-
- You were learning it through your head,
but not through your body, right.
- Yeah.
- I mean, we weren't using it.
Like we learn, it's like,
why this is important
they tell you, but it's like,
I don't fucking like, (mumbles)
- Have you guys ever had like a
proper real job interview
or anything like that?
- Yeah.
And it was rough.
(laughs)
- Well, yeah, I've had that.
- Was yours for like McDonald's?
- No, no, no for like-
- Like a real job.
- Oh, okay.
- So like, when I, before I
decided to do YouTube full time
I was actually still
applying for engineering jobs
'cause I was going to
do a year in placement.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Which is in,
I don't know if they do this in Australia.
You could basically, after
your second year in the UK-
- Oh, you have an industry, yeah.
- Yeah, it's an industry, yeah.
- Basically working.
- Yeah, you get paid to work
and you normally, it's normally those kids
who do really well in third year as well,
because they come into
it with a lot more like-
- Like an internship.
- Like practical experience.
Kind of like an internship.
- Yeah, yeah.
An internship that actually pays well.
And you normally get a job after it.
Like they're normally-
- Normally they, you get the job offer
for that placement after your year ends.
- And some of them might
even offer to pay for
the third year and the masters.
It's kind of like no downside of doing it,
especially in engineering.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- It's really good.
- The hardest part is getting
an offer in the first place.
- It's really hard to get
a good place to take you.
I remember I did tests for
like rolls Royce and stuff,
and they were hard.
Like they would make
every single one of them,
was so annoying.
You would apply for it
and they'd make you do this in
an hour and a half long test.
That was hard as shit.
And eventually you just got to
the point where you were like
I've done four of these in
one day and it took all day
and I know I'm not going
to get any of them.
Let's be honest,
I'm not smart enough to work
in Rolls Royce's jet engine.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
I'm just gonna be honest
dude that aint me.
And I had an interview for one
and I just remembered
them asking me questions
and I'm like, fuck, I can't
even like stomach the lies.
I can't even,
I don't even have the-
- You get in the business now.
- I care so little about
actually getting this job
that I couldn't even sit
there and lie to the guy.
Like I would in a normal job interview.
I would be like, of course I know.
- I never really like worked any job
like before YouTube became a job.
I mean like I told the story
of how I tried for McDonald's and failed
and then, I did one
internship, like during uni
but at that point, like YouTube
was kind of becoming more of a priority
that I knew I probably wasn't going to go
into this field anyway.
But like I'm not gonna
say the company name
but like last like two years or so
I've been approached by this
like relatively big company
like international that
like really wanted me.
- Oh, okay.
- And that was the first time where I went
into like an actual, like
proper job interview.
But I didn't do one interview,
I did 17 interviews.
- Holy shit.
- Not to mention,
I did some here in Japan
and then I also did some in LA.
- 17?
Fucking hell.
- Yeah.
I did some in LA so like, when I was
like staying at Archie's place in Vegas,
they like flew me out to LA
just to do like six more interviews.
- [Connor] Oh my God!
- Then I had to fly back
and at the end of the
day, I didn't get the job.
- I'd like to think that
after the 16th interview
they were like, I don't think so, but
let's try one more time.
(all laugh)
- And it was like a different
person every time as well.
- Yeah.
- So like, but this is
like a pretty big company.
Like, I'm pretty sure I'm
not allowed to say who,
but like it was a pretty big company.
And it was like, it was a company as well
because it's like, Oh, like
if YouTube falls through
this is a perfect place to work.
Like, hell yeah!
Like this is my plan B.
And so I was genuinely excited to be like,
maybe I might get this job.
I don't know.
But I think that just made
it so much more stressful-
- I remember, oh sorry go through.
- Because it was like, because
I was genuinely interested
but it's like, how do I
like tell that to the person
without sounding like
an absolute kiss ass.
- You actually do want to work there.
- It's like, yes, I
love everything you do,
of course I want to work for your company.
- So if you had got that
would you have quit YouTube?
- Hard to say.
- Wow.
- You can't say now that
with the place you're at in YouTube.
I remember every person in
their YouTube careers thought
maybe I'll get a proper
job because I don't
know when this will fall through.
- Yeah, right?
It was at that point where I was like,
I'll give myself maybe another year.
- There's a lot of anxiety and a lot of,
what's the word?
Like you don't trust it.
- Yeah.
You think it's temporary.
Even though, you know, it's not
there's always that gut feeling.
- And then I think I can
understand sometimes why,
some people YouTubers want to move on
and wanna to do something else.
I understand that I don't
have that interest right now
and I don't want to move on
because I'm really enjoying it.
But, you know, I'm starting to understand
after doing this for like five years
I can understand the mindset
of why someone wouldn't want to
be in that coin flip every day is like
well, let's see if I've got a job today.
- Yeah, right?
- It is kinda like, it is really stressful
and I think that I've
just become used to it.
But if you put someone in
this situation overnight
I feel like it's one of
those things where it's like-
- Oh, they wouldn't be able to handle it.
- Maybe not handle it,
but it would definitely
it would definitely wear on you I think.
- Oh, yeah, absolutely.
- Going back to job interview
so I do you have like a story
of like my very first I'd
say real job interview
'cause you know, I've had job interviews
for like Co-op and like call centers.
- They don't count.
- They don't really count.
We were talking like big-
- They just want to make sure
you're not a fucking criminal.
- Exactly.
All you have to do is
just be a competent person
and somehow Joey can be phrase of that
McDonald's interview, but
that's a different story
but like we're talking actual
like big boy companies.
Okay, you're here for
a specific skill set.
So this is like before
I got my job at the BBC
so as you do as a graduate
you apply to about 10
million different companies
and just hope one of them sticks.
So one, one company that
actually call me back
for an interview was a missile company.
So I would basically be kind of like-
- Like, (imitating missiles) missiles?
- Yeah, yeah, like (imitating missiles)
(laughs)
- What other missiles are there Joey?
- I don't know it's just
sounded really weird,
it's like a company that
makes missiles, like what?
- Is that the sound missiles make?
(imitating missiles)
So yeah, what would you do?
Yeah, I design (imitating missiles).
- Get down to the missiles are coming.
(Garnt laughs)
- But yeah it was a proper missile company
and I was applying to be
like a systems engineer
to like design and make missiles.
So like obviously, I go in the interview
and I'm fucking nailing
this interview, okay.
I can't remember how it is,
like the interview was split up into
two different segments.
Like there was the one
where like they interview
your like personality.
I don't know, I can't
remember what that's called
I know there's a technical term.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There's one where there like
they grill you about
why do you think you'd
be a fit in these company
and you say, you're a fucking team player,
you are a perfectionist.
- What do you want from me?
I'm gonna (speaking simultaneously)
- What are one of my weaknesses?
Oh, well, you know, I just I'm-
- I just love money.
- I am a perfectionist
and you can't fucking say,
look, I just need money
and I need to pay off
my fucking student loan.
Why are you asking me questions
that you know the fucking answer to, okay?
So well, like I, I
breezed through that and
I know I'm doing a good fucking job.
- Right, right.
- And then I get to the
technical interview,
and the technical interview,
I actually prepared for this, right?
Because you know, I'm
working for a fucking,
I'm applying to be a
fucking missile designer
so I should probably know the basics
of how a missile works, right.
And sure enough, I get to
the technical interview
and they ask me can you
explain the broad basics
about how a missile works, right.
And so-
- Then you go (imitates missiles)
(laughs)
- I go (imitates missiles)
No, so I'm sure I've mentioned this before
but my degree is in electronic
and electrical engineering.
So I was, so basically,
this was gonna be brief, I
know how a missile works.
So, I've done my research-
- He's done the studying.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so, I start, so
there's two interviewers
there's one older, serious guy
and then there's one like
younger, not exactly a graduate,
but he's been there for years, but
he's like at the time he was like
late twenties early thirties.
- The more understanding.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
So I start explaining
how this missile works.
So there's like a whiteboard
and like, so I draw the missile, right.
And, I'm like explaining, explaining
explaining everything.
I'm like, yada yada, here,
this system does this,
this system does this.
And so my final year degree
project, my thesis, sorry.
Was on like object, real
time, object tracking
and everything like that
So, perfect.
Perfect for what I need to explain here.
So I start explaining how this missile
like tracks different objects.
So I draw this rectangle
and I label that target.
And then I draw a dotted line
from the target to like this
missile that I've drawn, right.
And so I started explaining, okay,
this is how the tracking system works
and the tracking system is
in the front of this missile.
And so I code an off the
front of this missile, right.
And I'm fucking getting into this.
I'm like, okay, so this is, this is how,
this is how my experience
of my tracking degree
can like help with how I
can, like how a missile -
- Like your selling yourself, right?
- Yeah, I'm fucking selling myself.
I'm getting into it.
And then I look over
and then like the oldest
serious guy was just like,
Hmm, yeah, it's very in sweat.
And then the younger guy was like
trying to hold his laughter.
He was just like,
- Oh no, what did you
draw on the rocket gun?
- And then I look over,
and I'm thinking to myself, like,
why you laughing at what I'm doing.
- I'm killing this, why are you laughing?
- I'm fucking killing this,
my career is on the line here,
I just want to get a job.
What could you possibly be laughing at?
And then I look at what I drawn.
I've drawn a penis.
(Joey laughs)
- How?
How did you draw a penis?
- I've drawn a big girthy
penis pissing on a rectangle.
(laughter continues)
- How did you do that?
- I've actually got a picture, right?
(all laugh)
I've got to show you this picture.
- I was really hoping this story's climax
would be about a penis.
- I was figuring what he was saying
he was drawing on a board
something else was coming.
(Joey laughing)
Oh my God Garnt!
Oh my God!
(laughs)
- But like, I didn't realize
how much it looked like
a fucking penis until-
- That's a straight up
Johnny scenes girth, bro.
- It is a fucking girthy penis.
- That's a veiny motherfucker.
- And then as soon as I saw that,
as soon as I saw that, right.
I knew I failed
not because I was doing a bad job,
but you know when you're in the zone
and like, there's nothing that
could take me out of the zone
knowing that I've just
drawn a fucking penis
in front of two examinees.
And then after that I just start stumbling
and I forget everything I prepared.
- Right, right.
- Right.
- You failed that test?
- Yeah, yeah I-
- So you didn't get it?
- I didn't get it.
- Fuck dude.
- They specifically said, and that I did
super super well on my, like
the personality side of things.
But the technical side was lacking.
- Until you draw a phallic
object on the whiteboard.
- I had totally blocked out of my mind
that there was a, they ask
you technical questions
because I think I was
so fucking bad at it.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt Yeah.
- 'Cause I remember I had a
question and they were asking me
how turbines worked and
I knew how they worked.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But you know, when you are in a room
with like two really old men
who've been doing this for years
and they ask it like, they're
like, how do you shit?
Tell me how you shit.
Describe how you shit.
- What?
- It's like, I know how to shit,
but when they're looking at me like that
and they asking me that way,
I'm like, ah, ah, ah, so
yeah, the blades ah take the oxygen in
and they mix it with, am I right?
Is this is right?
This is right.
Yeah fuck.
I remember I just butchered it.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- But also did you video
interviews, but you did,
but there was no one to talk to?
- What?
- Video interviews.
- Or like on Skype and shit.
- So if you pass the test, right.
The math test and the personality, right?
They would say that you
wouldn't get an interview.
You got a video video interview where
all you could see is yourself
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Oh no, I never had that
but that sounds horrible.
- I've never had that.
- That must've have been as
like three times, three times.
And it was like,
so basically what it was
is, there would be a...
It fucking felt like a Mario fucking party
quick type of thing.
It would be, there would be a slide right?
Where you could see yourself
and it would cut to your question
and then it would be like five, four,
and then you have to answer
it and they were filming.
- [Joey] Oh my God!
- I was terrifying.
Like one of them was like, so stupid.
It was like, you know, it's going
and it's like, you know, like, okay.
And then it's like,
who's your biggest
engineering inspiration?
And I'm like,
(Garnt laughs)
but I don't fucking know.
- My engineering idol.
- I'm like, I just did
this for the degree.
I don't think about this shit.
I'm just trying to play
code like what do you mean?
And so I was like,
fuck! Fuck!
I shout like Einstein or something.
(all laugh)
I'm like,
(laughter continues)
And I'm not kidding, right?
I said Einstein, right.
I finished that question,
the next fucking thing is
two of seven questions.
The next thing I just
fucking all left four.
I'm like I haven't got this,
I'm fucking all left four.
- Einstein.
The most famous engineer in the world.
(all laugh)
- You might have heard of him.
- Because I was like,
there's no way I'm getting
it with an answer like that.
That's like asking what
your favorite meal?
White bread.
I love it.
I love white bread.
Potatoes.
It's like I literally altered
for the next question.
I was like, I'm not getting this,
I'm closing this.
Who fucking needs the
rest of the questions.
- Have you guys ever had
like group interviews?
- No.
- I remember I had one
and like, so this was
like at the second company
that I applied to.
And we had like a team
building interview, right.
- That sounds horrible already.
- Yeah and so our first task
was we were grouped up with another person
and I will never forget this person
even though he's a fucking genius
but I'll get to that later.
But like so our...
So there were work, there
were going to look it out
like our team building so
the very first task, right.
Was very simple so we
get paired with someone
and we had to like learn
as much information
about them as we can.
Like names, hobbies, yada, yada, yada
and then we'd have to like present that
to the group, right.
- Oh fuck.
- As like, I'm sure they saw it
as an icebreaker and
everything, but you know,
- It's the worst way to ice break.
- Testing out like communication
skills and listening skills
and all the basic fucking team
work and stuff we wanna do.
So I get paired up with Dan.
Thank you Dan.
So like we get paired up and
immediately he just goes,
Hey, my name is Dan,
so here's how you wanna do it
like, I'll say whatever
I want to say about you
and you just say, it's right
and you say whatever
you want to say about me
and I'll just say it's right.
So we don't have to worry about
this stupid icebreaker shit.
- Oh, I'm just like genius, genius.
- Giga brain.
So like, gets to our turn
he starts talking and he's, you know
he gets my name, right but
he just fucking makes up
everything else about me.
- An absolute Chad move.
- I like to play FIFA.
(all laugh)
- That's so smart.
- My favorite, like my
favorite film is like,
I can't even remember what
he fucking said back then.
- South of Western balls or some shit.
- Yeah and so then it gets to my turn
and I'm like, Hey this is Dan-
- He loves FIFA.
(all laugh)
- No, like a, yeah, he's
a, he's X years old,
he's like 23 years old
and he's like, nah 22.
I was like, yo, yo, are you
fucking doing this right now?
- Oh, that's genius.
- Are you fucking doing,
is he really fucking me
over like this right now?
(all laugh)
And I say, yeah, he likes
to play call of duty.
No, I don't like playing call of duty.
- Wow, top 10 anime betrayal-
- And I was just like, you motherfucker
you are fucking me over even
though it's fucking genius
'cause I am your competition.
I fucking hate you right
now but I can't hate you
because I should've thought of this.
- Oh that's a fucking movie villain shit.
Nah, I can't play someone like that,
that's too harsh.
Holy fuck.
- This man was playing
fucking five D chess in the-
- [Connor] No, kidding.
- Fucking hell.
I fucking hope he got the job.
Like Jesus Christ!
Could you imagine if he didn't
get the job after all that.
He just fucked you over for no reason.
- Hey man, doggy, dog,
world, I respect that.
I learned a harsh lesson that day
and I will never forget.
- There you go uni
graduates you can use that.
(all laugh)
Fuck over your opponents by that.
- But that seem like the
kind of thing where it's like
that's too good to be true
when someone else brings it to you right?
You son of a bitch that's fucking.
- Keep your enemies close as they say.
- Goddamn wow!
On that note that's been this
episode of the Trash Taste,
I guess.
- Hey look at all these patrons though.
Beautiful people who support the show.
- Now this guy would fuck
me over in a job interview.
(all laugh)
- I hope Dan was actually like Danny G.
- I'll ask for Danny G.
(laughter continues)
- But yeah, if you'd
like to support the show
then you can do so by going
over to trash taste patron
also follow us on the Subreddit
and the Twitter as usual.
Also listen to us over on Spotify
links to that down in
the description below.
- Hell yeah.
- And what else we want to shout out?
Thank you to everyone who
just joined our Subreddits.
Have you already shut out Twitter?
I completely zoned out.
- I did all of that.
- Okay.
I was just like Joey saying words
and I'm just like wait,
is it my turn to speak?
What am I supposed to say?
- Nah I've got you covered bro.
- Epic editing by Mudin.
Very Epic.
Very nice.
- Very nice.
- [Connor] Yes.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you for watching.
Bye.
- [Joey] Bye.
- [Garnt] Bye.
(soft music)